MORNING THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US.
WE WELCOME YOU TO THE STATE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO DO SOME
HOUSEKEEPING FIRST WE'VE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TUESDAY AB
SIXTY FIVE MISS PETRIE-NORRIS IN
AN ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. SEVEN
NINE MISTER BONTA.
PLEASE IN GERMAN ON ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE
THAT'S OUR LAST ITEM THE DAY
THAT'S GOING TO BE HEARD ON JULY
TENTH.
JULY TENTH.
WE HAVE A FULL DOCKET FOR OF
FOLKS HERE TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
STARTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP THE MEETING OFF WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FORTY EIGHT MISTER
O'DONNELL.
MISTER O'DONNELL -- COME ON FORD
SIR IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
YOU'RE DONE YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
GREAT NEWS -- YES PLEASE SAID
HEY YEAH BUT I ALWAYS EFFECTIVE
ALWAYS AS I HAVE ABOUT. FIVE
PAGES HERE SO I WILL AT SOME
POINT MAYBE JUMP AHEAD HEY THERE
YOU GO EXACTLY AND I DO
APOLOGIZE ARE GOING TO BE
STARTED I DO WANT TO SELL IT IS
IMPORTANT TOPIC IMPORTANT POLICY
IN SOMETHING WE NEED TO BE FOR
IT ON SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
BUT MAYBE AGAIN OR SIR SIR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WELL LET ME FIRST BY STATING I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR FINE WORK ON THIS.
AB FORTY EIGHT IS A VEHICLE FOR
K. FOURTEEN SCHOOL FACILITIES
BOND. TO BE PRESENTED TO VOTERS
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO K. TWELVE
FACILITY PROGRAM IS A HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT IS BASED
ON A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
DEVELOPERS.
STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN MATCH
MY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND LOCAL
LOCAL BOND FUNDS AND DEVELOPER
FEES TAKEN TO CONSTRUCT NEW
SCHOOLS.
AND ENHANCE EXISTING SCHOOLS
YOUR MODERNIZATION.
TOGETHER THESE FUNDS TO BUILD
NEW SCHOOLS MODERNIZE AGING
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE SAFE UPDATED AND SUPPORTED.
ANTS I SUPPORT OF A VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS AND LET ME JUST SAY
MISTER CHAIR FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
SCHOOL FACILITIES SET THE TONE
FOR THE DAY I THINK THEY SPEAK
TO A THE STATE'S INTEREST IN
EDUCATION AND INVESTMENT.
IN EDUCATION SOLDIERS JUMP AHEAD
RIGHT HERE AND JUST STAYED A FEW
THINGS ABOUT THIS BILL -- THIS
BILL DOES PROVIDE EQUITY FOR
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
BY ENSURING THAT SOME DISTRICTS
THAT CAN'T FINANCE SCHOOLS CAN
ACTUALLY GET ON A PERCENT.
OTHER FACILITIES FINANCED
THROUGH HARDSHIP PROGRAM -- WE
ALSO HAVE MONEY HERE FOR
DISASTER RELIEF -- REMEDIATION
AND LEAD AND WATER FOUNTAINS
REPLACEMENT A SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD BUILDINGS PRESCHOOLS AT
SCHOOL SITES.
AND WE SUPPORT FACILITIES SUCH
AS GYMNASIUMS LIBRARIES AND AND
AND SCHOOL KITCHENS -- SO WITH
THAT I'M JUST GONNA TURN OVER A
TODAY WELL WITH ME HERE TODAY IS.
BOB YOU FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION A JEFF
BECKER.
FROM THE PHEASANT FRESNO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WHICH IS
AGAIN LET ME STATE THERE IS A
VARIETY OF MECHANISMS -- FOR IT
BUILT INTO THIS THIS THIS
APPROACH THAT ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO FINANCE OUR OWN
PROJECTS TO FINANCE THEM.
SO THERE IS AGAIN EQUITY BUILT
INTO THIS PROGRAM THERE'S BEEN
SOME CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT
WHICH WILL CONTINUE.
BUT THERE IS MISTER CHAIR IF I
TURN IT OVER YOU MAY TURN OVER
TO THE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT
MISTER O'DONNELL IS DONE ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
IT IS BEEN A BUSY YEAR TO SAY
THE LEAST.
IN THIS IS SUCH A CRITICAL
MEASURE WILL HAVE SOME COMMENTS
ON THIS YEAR AND JUST A BIT WILL
TURN OVER MISTER BAKI WITH THE
CONFERENCE SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
SPIKE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES FOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS IS COULD YOU
SEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
RESEARCH SAYS THAT ADEQUATE A
MODERN FACILITIES ARE ESSENTIAL
TO STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SIMPLY
CANNOT FULFILL THEIR ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL IF ATTENTION IS NOT
GIVEN TO ENSURE THE FACILITIES
ARE CLEAN AND SAFE. FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM.
AND HAVE DONE SO IN THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE.
THIS PARTNERSHIP AS BENEFITTED
MORE THAN SIX MILLION STUDENTS
AND TALKING WITH HER MEMBERS
THERE SIX SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
A. B..
FORTY EIGHT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PASSAGE A LOCAL SCHOOL BONDS
REVIEW LOCAL FACILITIES MASTER
PLANS.
YOU'LL QUICKLY RECOGNISE THE
VOLUME WORK THAT STILL
OUTSTANDING AS THE ANALYSIS
INDICATES THERE IS FOUR POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS
AUTHORITY WITH OVER FIVE BILLION
IN APPLICATIONS ALREADY
SUBMITTED.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE A NEED TO
CONSTRUCT NEW BUILDINGS IN AREAS
WHERE THERE STUDENT GROWTH
THAT'S NO DOUBT.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE A NEED TO
UPDATE EXISTING SYSTEMS RAKE
RECONFIGURE EXISTING FACILITIES
TO CREATE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
THAT MEET THE SCHOOLS NEXT
GENERATION GOALS.
OR PROVIDES A SIMPLE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS THE LIST GOES ON
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
STATE AND LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IS A CRITICAL ELEMENT IN
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS.
THE DEBT SERVICE COSTS TO THE
STATE MATCH BY LOCAL FUNDS
REFLECT THE APPROPRIATE AND
REASONABLE INVESTMENT IN OUR
STUDENTS. FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF FORTY EIGHT
HOW MUCH I TO SEE SB A WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME SIR BAKER TO
COMMITTEE OF TWO MINUTES SIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
MORNING CHAIRMAN WHY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JEFF BACKER I AM THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
AND OPERATIONS. FOR THE FRESNO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS
I'M ALSO SERVING AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING.
WE'RE GONNA BE JUST PULL THAT
MIKE LOOK CLOSER I I APOLOGIZE
FOR HAVING NO PROBLEM.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
VOTERS HAVE APPROVED OVER FORTY
TWO BILLION IN STATE BONDS TO
FUND K. TWELVE SCHOOL FACILITIES
LOCAL COMMUNITIES DEVELOPERS AND
THE STATE ARTNER. TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE CLEAN FACILITIES.
AB FORTY EIGHT KEEPS THAT THREE
LEGGED STOOL INTACT.
NOW THAT THE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM IS OVER TWENTY YEARS OLD
IT IS TIME TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO ENSURE ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM.
AB FORTY EIGHT CREATES NEW TOOLS
FOR SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND THOSE WHO ARE FISCALLY DID
AS DISADVANTAGED THESE INCLUDE
AN UP FRONT RESERVATION A BOND
AUTHORITY TO ENSURE DOLLARS ARE
AVAILABLE WHEN SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE READY TO REQUEST
THEIR CONSTRUCTION FUNDING.
AND A NEW GRANT FOR PROJECT AND
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY AB FORTY EIGHT
MAINTAINS THE IMPORTANT
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP PROGRAM.
WHICH HELPS SCHOOLS MEET THEIR
LOCAL MATCH WHEN THEY DO NOT
HAVE SUFFICIENT LOCAL RESOURCES.
REGARDINGTHE USE OF BOND
FINANCING WE TYPICALLY SPEND
122% OF THE STATE'S ANNUAL
GENERAL FUND TO PAY K. TWELVE
SCHOOL BOND DEBT SERVICE.
WITH A. B. FORTY EIGHT WILL
CONTINUE TO LIVE WITHIN OUR
MEANS WITHOUT A MEANINGFUL
INCREASE TO THAT ANNUAL COST.
WELL THEY'RE STILL REMAINING
FUND BALANCE FROM PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED BONDS THE CORE NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
PROGRAMS ARE NOW OVERSUBSCRIBED.
WITH ALMOST FOUR AND A HALF
BILLION IN PROJECTS AWAITING
FINAL PROCESSING AND FINDING AN
APPLICATION SUBMITTED TODAY.
WOULD REQUIRE PASSAGE OF THE NEW
BOND TO BE FUNDED.
DISTRICTS HAVE SUBMITTED OVER
SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN
APPLICATIONS IN ACCESS OF
EXISTING BOND AUTHORITY AND THE
BACKLOG WILL CONTINUE TO GROW.
THE SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR DISTRICTS ALL ACROSS
THE STATE INCLUDING IN MY OWN
BACKYARD IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHERE MANY OF THE SCHOOLS WILL
BE UNABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
CRITICAL PROJECTS WITHOUT THE
STATE'S ASSISTANCE? FOR THESE
REASONS I OUR DRIVER.
BAKER WE'VE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE TODAY TO GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY MR DONNA WE'D LIKE TO
GET A STYLISH REQUIREMENT THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU BEFORE WE GO TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS LANCASTER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
WHY A PRESENT? FOR A LOT.
OR NOT PRESIDENT BELL HERTZBERG.
RICARDO NIELSEN.
NIELSEN PRESIDENT WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER PRESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS THANK YOU
SIR QUORUM IS PRESENT LADIES IN
GENERAL NOT GONNA WELCOME ANYONE
WHO'S IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF
YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD.
LOOKING FOR FOLKS AT FIRST AND
LAST AN ORGANIZATION GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME BY DOING
MORE CHAMBERS AND NASH OVER THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH SAM.
GOOD MORNING OR MISTER MEMBERS
AS ARE THE OTHER BEHALF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL STRONG SUPPORT.
YES. ONE IN.
THE MORNING THE CALL RISE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU RISE.
MORNING GOOD MORNING PATTY HER
ON BEHALF OF THE CROWN ON ORACLE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
MORNING.
INTO DEAL WITH THE COUNTY SCHOOL
FACILITIES CONSORTIUM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONSTRUCTION
MANAGERS AND THE THAT'S IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ELIZABETH ASK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS OF
SUPPORT THANKS FOR BEING HERE A
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING DEREK
LANCE ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATIONAL
TECHNOLOGY PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION.
THE SAN BERNADINO COUNTY
ADVOCATES FOR BETTER SCHOOLS IF
YOU WORK ON WE HAVE A SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU GOOD MORNING.
IT WAS A CLEAN ON BEHALF OF THE
SENSES BUT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE SOLANO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
IN THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION ON SUPPORT BUDGET
OUT THANK YOU SO MUCH MORNING
GOOD MORNING OKAY SHILOH WOULD
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT IS OVER.
MORNING.
LARA PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
IN SUPPORT ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
LAUREN COMMITTEE WITH YOU GOOD
MORNING ANDREA BALL FIRST ON
BEHALF OF MERRY JANE BURKE THE
MARIN COUNTY.
SUPERINTENDENT SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT IN ADDITION THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EDUCATION COALITION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT WE LOVE TO PRETEND BURKE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD MORNING NANCY TRIED
ASSISTING US ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION AND THE SCHOOLS ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JEFF FLOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUPERINTENDENTS
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
THANKS SO MUCH YEAH HEY GOOD
MORNING MORNING WAS THAT NEVER
AT ON BEHALF OF ME CALL TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY TWO
DISTRICTS HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING MORNING RICHARD LION
ON BEHALF OF THE HOME BUILDERS
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY OF
FUNDING PARTNER IN THE PROGRAM
FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU RICHARD.
THANK YOU I CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD ON BEHALF OF THE
FOOTHILL DE ANZA KERN.
SAN BERNARDINO SAN FRANCISCO IN
YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE MORNING HAVING TROUBLE WITH
THE COUNTY NO FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FLEXIBLE
EDUCATORS AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS FOR BEING HERE MORNING.
GOOD MORNING FOR THE JOPLIN JAVA
THE **** PROJECT CALIFORNIA VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IN ADDRESSING SOME
OF THE INEQUITIES IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GIVE ME A LAST CALL FOR THOSE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
LAST CALL.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE'RE
LOOKING PROPOSITION IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME.
FOR LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO GIVE SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND
WE'RE GONNA SAY GOOD MORNING TO
THE VICE CHAIR AND THE TO MISTER
NIELSEN.
VICE CHAIR.
MISTER.
I'LL BE THE OPPOSITION THEN. TO
HAVE SOMEONE A MESS OF THE
PUNCHBOWL -- CINNAMON.
O'DONNELL I WILL THIS BE PAID
OUT OF NINETY EIGHT IS TH IS
THE GENERAL FUND COMES OUT OF
THE STATE GENERAL FUND --
THIRTEEN BILLION IN.
FIND DENTAL BE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND AND SOMEONE
INTEREST PAYMENTS THAT'S GONNA
COME OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND
WHERE DOES IT.
BUT CHECK COME UP WORDS THAT
COME FROM WHAT WE WHAT WE PUSH
OUT OF THE WAY.
IT'S ALL ABOUT PRIORITIES AND
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
EDUCATION AND THUS EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES SHOULD BE A PRIORITY
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
YOU INVEST IN A SCHOOL FACILITY.
YOU INVEST IN A CHILD WHEN YOU
INVEST IN A CHILD YOU INVEST IN
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
NO ARGUMENTS THERE BUT WE HAVE
PROP NINETY EIGHT WHY DO WE JUST
PAY IT OUT OF THEIR THIS IS WILL
EXPAND.
I'M SORRY WE JUST GET OUT OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING THAT
WE'VE GOT 40% OF THE BUDGET
DEDICATED TO OUR CHILDREN.
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY THE
GENERAL FUND WOULD HAVE TO TAKE
ALMOST TWELVE RECORDS WITH
BILLION IN A NEW EXPENSE AYE I
WOULD ARGUE THAT.
PROP NINETY EIGHT IS ENOUGH THE
FINER EDUCATIONAL.
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA FACTORY
LOOK [inaudible]
ABOUT WHAT. FORTY SIX AND FOR
PEOPLE FUNDING SO IF WE WERE
TAKE THIS MONEY OUT OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WOULD
FURTHER IMPACT ON THE NEGATIVE
SIDE.
HOW MUCH WE CAN INVEST IN OUR
STUDENTS?
I DON'T ARGUE THAT AT ALL I
THINK I AGREE WITH YOU THAT PROP
NINETY EIGHT IS NOT SUFFICIENT
QUESTION WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE.
AND HOW BIG THEIR UNRESTRICTED
NET DEFICITS ARE IT'S SCARY.
TENSIONS IN THE RETIREE MEDICAL
JUST KILLING HER OUR DISTRICTS --
BUT I'M I'M TRYING TO FIND MONEY
TO REDUCE THOSE THAT SO THEY CAN
HAVE MORE MONEY IN THEIR BUDGETS
AND LOWER THEIR ANNUAL.
SO IF YOU LOOK ON PAGE SEVEN OF
THE STAFF REPORTED IT SHOWS THE
TEN LARGEST STATES AND IT SHOWS
THAT CALIFORNIA.
IS IN THE THREE BOTTOM WHEN IT
COMES.
TO THE THE AMOUNT OF THAT
PERSONAL INCOME THE DEBT PER
CAPITA AND THE DEBT AS A
PERCENTAGE OF STATE GDP WEEK WE
ARE WORK.
ALREADY GOT SO MUCH.
THAT COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IN.
AND WE HAVE AS A STATE WE HAVE A
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT
TALK.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL.
STRUCTURE OF THE STATE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND I'M JUST YOU KNOW SPEAKING
AS JUST.
ONE PERSON THAT KIND OF BOOK
DONE FINANCES.
I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE PAY FOR HOW.
TO HOW DO WE MAKE IT ALL FIT AND
SO.
BECAUSE OF THAT.
SYMON O'DONNELL AYE I'M GONNA BE
A NO VOTE AND IT'S JUST BECAUSE
I'M SAYING NO TO JUST ABOUT
EVERY.
BONDAGE I THINK THAT'S IT I'VE
BEEN CONSISTENT WITH YOU HAVE.
I AND I'M.
NO AND I HAVE A TEACHER THAT'S A
SCHOOL TEACHER.
YOU KNOW ANAHEIM UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO.
I'LL BUT I'M JUST SAYING I GOT A
WERE. FOR ME SIR YOU WERE MY
BROTHER OKAY BROTHERS -- IS HE
LISTENING RIGHT NOW.
I GET TO HEAR FROM HIM.
WE DO HAVE FAMILY EVENTS.
AND THE AND SO BUT BUT BECAUSE
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE WHOLE
AND IN IN THIS IS NOT THE ONLY
BOND MEASURE THAT'S COME BEFORE
US SO THEY ALL PASS.
I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
DO IT.
AND WE'RE READY HIGHS TAX STATE
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT.
WHAT WE DO SO LIKE YOU SAID IT'S
ALL ABOUT PRIORITIES AND I THINK
WE OUGHT TO START?
PRIORITIZING AND ONE OF THOSE IS
TO REDUCE OUR DATA THAT WOULD BE
THE PENSIN PLAN.
AND RETIREE MEDICAL LA UNIFIED
WAS HERE.
THEY JUST HAD TO PUT FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS ON THEIR BALANCE
SHEET.
IN RETIREE MEDICAL THAT.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES MISTER THAT.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD BE FORMING.
HEARINGS AND AND LOOKING AT HOW
DO WE HELP THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE
OF THE FINANCIAL.
ACTUATION IS AWFUL OAKLAND
SACRAMENTO CITY EGGMAN CITIES
WAS ABOUT A MONEY IN NOVEMBER.
IN INDIA AND SO HOW DO WE
CONVINCE VOTERS THAT WE GOT A
HELP THE STUDENTS WERE BUSY
BUILDING NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S A DISCONNECT.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME.
DOWN ON MY SOAPBOX MR DONALD
SAILOR TO THE WIFE.
THANK YOU SAID.
I I JUST ARE YOU LISTEN IF YOU
CAN'T IF YOU CAN'T -- IF YOU
CAN'T BUILD A SCHOOL YOU CAN'T
EDUCATED STUDENT.
AND I THINK THIS BOND EFFORTS
SPEAKS AGAIN TO OUR STATES
PRIORITIES COMES OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND I THINK BUT I KNOW
BOND FINANCING ISIN SO LONG.
ACCEPTED METHOD.
OF FINANCING OUR SOCIAL OVERHEAD
CAPITAL IF YOU WILL ITS USE IN
THE BUSINESS WORLD AS WELL.
AND HISTORICALLY INTEREST RATES
ARE RELATIVELY CHEAP RIGHT NOW
SO I THINK THIS IS WHERE.
WE SHOULD GO WE SHOULD WE SHOULD
TAKE OUR CASH AND PAID ON A
LONGER TERM RETIREE DEBT
SUPPORTER PENSIONERS I THINK
YOU'RE ONE RIGHT WE WANNA KEEP
PROPAGATION TO THOSE FOLKS.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOU AND YOUR
APPRECIATION FOR BEING FISCALLY
PRUDENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE VICE
CHAIR.
WE'RE GONNA CENTER NIELSEN.
GOOD MORNING.
WE CAPITAL OUTLAY.
CONSTRUCTION HAS BEEN A SEPARATE
BOND ISSUE FOR DECADES.
AS ALLOCATED TO THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD WITH THE HELP
OR SOMETIMES I WOULD CALL IT THE
INTERFERENCE.
OF THE STATE ARCHITECT.
THEY HAVE SOMETIMES BEEN A BIT
OF A PROBLEM.
I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT DEGREE THEY
ARE NOW BUT I SERVE MANY YEARS
ON THAT.
ALEX.
AND THAT WAS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE REHABILITATION.
AND SO CONSTRUCTION.
NOW WE'RE ADDING A FEW.
ITEMS TO THAT LIST THAT THEY
CONSIDER.
DOES ANYONE KNOW IF THE
ALLOCATION BOARD HAS UPDATED ITS
REGULATIONS TO ACCOMMODATE THESE
NEW DISTRIBUTION OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE BEING CONSIDERED.
YES I I I CAN ANSWER THAT SO THE
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION AND IN.
AS FAR AS PROVIDING BANDWIDTH IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THERE ARE TEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED. TO THE OFFICE
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION THAT
OVERSEES A STATE ALLOCATION
BOARD.
THE REASON BEING IS THAT THERE
WERE SOME DELAYS IN PROCESSING
OF BOND PROJECTS COMING THROUGH
THE STATE ALLOCATION BOARD.
AND WE JUST MOVED ON THAT -- AND
DO BELIEVE THAT IS CAN ASSIST --
IN THE BACKLOG.
OF A PROJECTS TO BE A TO MOVE
THEM OUT QUICKER WHICH IS GOOD
NEWS IN THEIR NIELSEN HAD ME ON
THE HEAD WE GOTTA GET THIS MONEY
OUT ON THE STREET QUICKER.
OUR KIDS DEPEND ON IT IN%
ADDITIONAL MONEY HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED PLEASE THE SERVER MAY
I SIT ON STATE ALLOCATION BOARD --
AND WHAT I CAN SHARE WITH YOU AS
WE THEY AREN'T THEY HAVEN'T
CONTEMPLATED A DOG ADOPTING
REGULATIONS FOR LAW THAT DOES
NOT YET EXIST.
SO HOULD THIS PASS I'M SURE THE
THE THE THE STATE EDUCATION
FOURTEEN WOULD GO TO WORK
IMMEDIATELY AND AND
CONTEMPLATING BRING FORWARD TO
THE BOARD.
SOME REGULATIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
WITH THE NEW LAW.
BUT AGAIN WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE STATE ARCHITECT -- I THINK
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK.
WITH THEM WITH THAT OFFICE OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS BECAUSE WHAT
I IMMEDIATELY HEARD -- WHEN I
GOT HERE AND STARTED TALKING TO
THE SCHOOL FACILITY FOLKS WAS
THERE WERE A LOT OF HURDLES PUT
UP BY THE STATE ARCHITECTS
OFFICE AND WHAT I'M HEARING IS
THAT THINGS ARE GETTING MUCH?
BETTER OVER THERE AND MUCH MORE
FRIENDLY AND A MUCH MORE
EXPEDITIOUS PROCESS HAS BEEN A
SALAS GET PROJECTS THROUGH.
THE STATE ARCHITECTS OFFICE
THEY'VE BEEN RATHER RESPONSIBLE
LAST FEW YEARS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE DO WE NEED TO DO
MORE.
ABSOLUTELY BUT WE HAVE A GOOD
START [inaudible]
GOOD [inaudible]
WELL.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I WILL SUPPORT.
NO SMALL MEASURE BECAUSE MY LONG
HISTORY WITH THAT AND THE NEEDS.
WE DO HAVE SOME DECLINING
ENROLLMENT.
TO SCHOOLS AROUND CALIFORNIA TO
THAT'S A NEW PHENOMENA WE'RE
DEALING WITH BUT THAT IS SIMPLY
TAKE SOME OF THE IMPACT OFF THE
DEMANDS ON THE BOND.
AND I SUPPOSE I'M NOT TOO
CONCERNED ABOUT EXPANDING THE
DIFFERENT THINGS ARE GOING --
BUT MONEY INTO THROUGH THE
ALLOCATION BOARD AND I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH THE ALLOCATION
PROCESS.
THAT IT GENERALLY HAS BEEN A
PROCESS IMBUED WITH INTEGRITY
AND CONFIDENCE AND PEOPLE
TRUSTED.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT HAS
DIMINISHED AT ALL HAS IT YOU WHO
ARE IN THE FIELD DEALING WITH IT
ALL THE TIME DELEGATION BOARD.
WELL I'LL BE SUPPORT THANK YOU
SENATOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE NIELSEN
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THOSE COMMENTS
AND FOR ALLOF YOUR WORK AS WELL
AS A PREVIOUS MEMBER AS HE
ALLOCATION BOARD.
I'M SURE DONALD JUST VERY
QUICKLY ON ON ISSUES OF SOME
COMMENTS AND HOW THEY RELATE.
K. TWELVE BUT THEN ALSO ON BONDS.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT PIECES
THAT MR O'DONNELL NAY ON THE
HEAD REGARD TO PROP.
NINETY EIGHT WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES.
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING OF THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS. FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE PER STUDENT.
COMPARED TO EIGHT YEARS AGO.
AND AS MISTER O'DONNELL HAD
ALREADY MENTIONED WE ARE WELL
BEHIND THE PACK WHEN IT COMES A
PER PUPIL SPENDING HERE IN
AMERICA.
IF WE WERE TO TAKE [inaudible]
BOND PAYMENT [inaudible]
FINANCING.
OUT FROM POT NINETY EIGHT OUT
PRESS FURTHER BEHIND.
WE TAKE A LOOK AT PENSIONS.
AT THIS LEGISLATURE'S ADVANCING.
A THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR DOWN PAYMENT ON THE STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
OUR SYSTEM.
THIS YEAR.
WE PUT SIX BILLION DOWN LAST
YEAR THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM [inaudible]
EVERY TEACHER.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE IN THE STATE
ARE PAYING MORE.
THEN THEY HAVE TEN YEARS AGO.
IN WHAT WE ALSO KNOW THAT EACH
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
IS HAVING TO ADVANCE ENHANCE
FUNDING. FOR BOTH THE STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
IN FACT THAT IS CREATED TENSION.
BECAUSE THE DISTRICTS ARE
ADVANCING [inaudible]
ENHANCE FUNDING.
WHICH THEN MEANS.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE ALLOCATED
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS FOR HAVING
PUT MORE TOWARDS PENSIONS.
AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU MY POINT
OF VIEW. THIRTY GOOD YEARS UNDER
PAYMENTS.
AND NOW WE'RE PLAYING CATCH UP --
THERE'S THREE WAYS WE CAN PAY
DOWN THIS DEBT.
IN THE STATE IS ADVANCING
[inaudible] ONE THE STATE
ADVANCES ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO PAY
DOWN STATE TEACHER RETIREMENT
SYSTEM DEBT. THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN THE BUDGET. TWO
INDIVIDUALS.
HAVE ENHANCED PAYMENTS THAT'S
HAPPENING EVEN AS WE SPEAK.
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ALSO
ADVANCING ENHANCE PAYMENTS INTO
THE STATE TEACHERS RETIREMENT
SYSTEM.
AND THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
IN REGARDS TO THE ISSUE OF BONDS.
THE THE FUNDING THAT WE HAVE
LEFT.
IN THE PREVIOUS BOND IS OVER
PRESCRIBED.
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
I WILL SHARE WITH YOU SEEN THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS IN SOME OF THE
MOST RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THIS
STATE -- LIFE CHANGING.
WE HAVE ENTIRE SCHOOLS IN
TRINITY COUNTY [inaudible]
THAT HAVE.
WHERE KIDS CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL IN
BECAUSE OF MOLD?
IT HAD TO PUT PORTABLES ON TO
THE PLANE FIELDS.
AND STUDENTS ARE NOW NO LONGER
ALLOWED IN THE MAIN BUILDING.
UNACCEPTABLE IN THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
WE HAVE KIDS THAT ARE UNABLE TO
GO INTO THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE OF
SUCH SIGNIFICANT MOLD CHALLENGES.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
BOND. FOR TO BE ABLE TO
MODERNIZE.
OUR CLASSROOMS KEEP KIDS IN
STAFF SAFE.
IN CANDIDLY.
pSO I APPRECIATE HARD WORK.
THAT DECEMBER -- HAS BEEN.
FOR DANCING ON THIS BILL ON THIS
BOND WHEN I TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE COALITION AS
WELL AS A COALITION IS OFTEN IT.
UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND WILL HAVE -- THE SOME NUMBER
MAKE CLOSING COMMENTS.
THAT'S WHEN I MOMENT MISTER.
THIS IS JIM WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
SEE IF SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE A MOTION ON THE
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
NIELSEN THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
IS LANCASTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WIRE.
WHY I'M MORE LOCKED?
OR LOCK NOBEL HERTZBERG HELLO.
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
IT'S CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO ONE
VOTE.
IF YOU'RE SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS TO THE
COALITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE DISCUSSION ALSO.
WITH MR NIELSEN IN THE VICE
CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL AS ALWAYS.
FOR THE GOOD.
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THAT
RELEVANT THANK YOU SIR.
ISN'T THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR THIS IS AB.
SEVEN OH SEVEN WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO LISTEN LIMóN KALRA.
WHO DOES SUCH A GREAT JOB? FOR
HIS PATIENTS TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR.
I'M MISTER KALRA YOU HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR IN YOUR
WITNESSES HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH
WHEN YOU GIVE US THIRTY SECONDS
LET FOLKS -- EXIT AND THEN -- GO
PRETTY FAR AWAY.
NUMBER THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MISS SHERRI BE SEVEN OH
SEVEN IS A DISTRICT BILL WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION X..
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT FOR THE
ANALYSIS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE OF THE AS WELL AS
OPERATING ENGINEERS LABORS AND
SEE FACT FOR WORKING WITH US TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT.
AB SEVERAL SEVERAL CHRIS THE CAP
ON WORK DONE BY SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATERS COURSE ACCOUNT
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS LIMITED
EXCEPTIONS IN THE CASE OF
CHANNEL MAINTENANCE
ENVIRONMENTAL PRESERVATION.
HABITAT MANAGEMENT OR EMERGENCY
WORK THIS PROCESS MORE WORKABLE
FOR WOMEN AND MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES I WILL INCREASE
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AB SEVEN OH SEVERAL BRING
GREATER PARITY BUSINESS CENTER
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT.
AND OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES A
LITTLE MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
TIMELY PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS
BELOW. FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF A CALENDAR
FROM VALUE WATER AND SELENA
PRIOR FROM THEN DOUBLE ACP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
WE'RE GONNA START SELENA DO YOU
WANT TO KICK US OFF ORDERS
RECORD TO KICK US OFF IDEA WHEN
I I WILL KISS.
RIGHT ALL RIGHT THE MINISTER WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK
YOU A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
WHERE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
RECOUNTED CHIEF OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT NOW KNOWN AS THE
VALLEY WATER.
WE'RE SPECIAL DISTRICT THAT IS
THE WATER SUPPLY FLOOD
PROTECTION STREAM STORESHIP
AGENCY THE TWO MILLION PEOPLE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN SIMPLY UPDATES
ARE AGENCIES THRESHOLD FOR
FORMAL BID CONTRACTING TO KEEP
UP WITH INFLATION THIS THRESHOLD
HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BY
INCREASING THE FOR BY INCREASING
THE FORMAL BID THRESHOLD VALLEY
WATER WILL BE ABLE TO USE THE
INFORMAL BID REQUIRED BY OUR
ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS. FOR
MINOR PUBLIC WORKS UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT INFORMAL
BID POLICY REQUIRES MULTIPLE
BIDS AND AWARDS THE JOB TO THE
LOWEST RESPONSE OF BETTER.
IT ALSO MAKES BIDDING EASIER FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE VALUE WATER OR JUST
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI SEVEN OH
SEVEN THINK SO MUCH MEANING
THANKS TO MAKE THE TREK UP TO
SACRAMENTO.
IS LANE GOING ON OR IS RUNNING.
HI MY NAME IS SELENA PRIOR
MEMBERS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CONFERENCE OF THE AND EE CP.
THE END OF LACI PIECE SUPPORTS
POLICIES THAT HELP PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND BUSINESSES OPEN
DOORS FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR TO
GAIN ACCESS TO CONTRACTS.
AND THAT CREATE A FULLY DIVERSE
WORK ENVIRONMENT.
BY RESTORING THE PURCHASING
POWER OF VALLEY WATERS FORMAL
BIT THRESHOLD AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
WOULD HELP SMALL BUSINESSES AND
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES.
COMPETE FOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS AND SILICON VALLEY.
BECAUSE OF A LONG HISTORY OF
DISCRIMINATION MANY MINORITY AND
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
JUST CREATED IN THE RELATIVELY
RECENT PASS AND MANY LACK THE
RESOURCES TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
EXTENSIVE CUMBERSOME FORMAL
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTING PROCESS.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
VALLEY WATERS FORMAL BID CON%
FORMAL BID CONTRACTING THRESHOLD
HAS BEEN ERODED BY INFLATION AND
IS NOW WORTH ROUGHLY HALF OF
WHAT IT WAS IN.
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THAT MEANS
EVERY YEAR THERE ARE FEWER AN
FEWER PROJECTS AVAILABLE FOR
MINORITY.
AND WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES TO
THE INFORMAL BID PROCESS I URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
AND HELP LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
MINORITY AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES.
THAT BUILT THE VALLEY WATER
PROJECTS THAT PRO TO PROTECT AND
SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU
THANKS SO MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL
YOU'RE HERE THANKS FOR COMING UP.
IS IN GENERAL NOT GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO THOSE WHO AY BE IN
SUPPORT IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FOR THIS TIME WE'RE LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
LAST CALL.
WE'RE NOT GONNA OPEN UP FOR
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADVANCE THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSE.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO BE RECEIVING IN THE
CONVERSATION IN A POTENTIAL
MOTION MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WE CAN HAVE SOME OPPOSITION
RIGHT.
NOW NO HOSTED EVER ME MR.
THE CINNAMON KALRA I'M JUST
CURIOUS WHY THIS IS IN STATE
CODE.
THIS. TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR LIMIT.
DID YOU KNOW THE HISTORY OR WHY
IT WAS.
BECAUSE WHY WHY WE FORCING THE
WATER DISTRICT I'M HERE.
TO CHANGE YOUR WHY DO WE JUST
CHANGE THAT CODE.
THIS IS A LOCAL MANAGEMENT
CONTROL ISSUE.
I'M JUST WONDERING.
IF YOU AND I NEED TO JOINT
AUTHORED A BILL LIKE THAT.
THE CHAIRMAN MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY -- THIS WAS
DONE A LONG TIME AGO AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY A LOT OF DIFFERENT
RULES BASED ON DIFFERENT TYPES
OF SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND IT IS
CONVOLUTED IN COMPLICATED I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SOLUTION TO IT.
I'M IF THERE'S A GESTIONES I'M
I'M ALL YEARS.
IN THE MEANTIME NO I I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT LEAST VALUE WATER
CAN UPDATE.
THEIR AMOUNT BUT THERE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT.
THE I'VE LEARNED A LOT OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS.
ABOUT -- HOW CONVOLUTED IT CAN
BE AND HOW DESPERATE THE
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS ARE BASED ON
THE TYPE OF AGENCIES SO?
YOU'RE CORRECT THAT IT PROBABLY
WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE TO NOT
HAVE TO COME. TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO PUT THE SPECS AND SO -- BUT
THE WAY THE OF THE OF THE
CURRENT STATE OF AFFAIRS
REQUIRES IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF WATER DISTRICT
HAVE AND MANY ARE THERE.
THREE THOUSAND IN THE STATE SO
IT'S LIKE HOW MANY BILLS AND DO
THAT ENOUGH BILLS.
HELP MANAGERS MANAGE.
WHO KNOWS MAYBE THERE'S AN IDEA
THAT WOULD BE OFF MAYBE I'LL
STEAL IT MYSELF?
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF THE DR CALLER.
NO THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT IS
RIGHT HERE YEAH IT LOOKS I THINK
THE VICE YOUR BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT.
LAST YEAR WE WORKED WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES.
FINE I INCREASING THE THRESHOLD
FOR AG OPEN SPACE DISTRICTS AND
REGIONAL PARKS.
HE WAS COMING IN -- FOR A COUPLE
OF SPECIFIC DISTRICTS AND THEN
WE RAISE THE THRESHOLD. FOR THEM
SO WE WOULDN'T CONTINUE TO SEE
AT THAT COULD BE AN ISSUE IN
REGARD TO WATER DISTRICTS.
I WAS JUST ASKING MISTER
PETERSON I HOW LONG IT'S BEEN
CODY'S BEEN COACH SINCE.
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE FIVE SO AT
THIS MAY BE AN ITEM HAS EVERY GO
AN ITEM THAT MAY BE AT ADVANCE.
IN THE FUTURE.
I'M LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OR DO WE ALSO A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
THIS IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR.
I MISTER CARR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MS MANCHESTER IF YOU WANT TO
CALL THE ROLL.
WIRE HI WHERE I'D MORE LOT MORE
LIKE AYE BELL HERTZBERG AUTO
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
ENJOY THE THREE ZERO VOTES
CARVER GONNA KEEP THAT BILL.
THANKS MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
COULD SEE THANK YOU.
WELCOME THE CHAIRWOMAN OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE TO THE DICE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY IS HERE THIS IS AB.
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO OUT FOCUSING
ON PROPERTY TAXATION.
I MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU DO HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
CHAIRMAN SHE IS SUCH A PLEASURE
TO WORK WITH TRULY.
YOU REALLY ARE AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT TO TREASURES
OFFICE -- IS HERE IS WELL
AGUIAR-CURRY THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS ONE I THINK OF THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF OF THE AWFUL
ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL AND A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT.
AB SEVEN TWO WILL HELP CHILDREN
ON SMALL FAMILY FARMS STAY IN
THEIR HOME AFTER THE DEATH OF A
PARENT.
OR A CHILD EXCLUSIONS GENTLY
PREVENT PROPERTY TAX
REASSESSMENT -- WHEN PROPERTY
CHANGES HANDS WITHIN THE FAMILY
FROM PARENT TO CHILD?
THIS LEGISLATURE WORLD THIS IS
FULLY CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED.
THESE EXCLUSIONS BECAUSE THEY
HELP CHILDREN STAY IN THEIR
FAMILY HOME AFTER THE LOSS OF A
TO THE SMALL GAP IN A
COMPLICATED TAX LAWS NOT ALSO MY
SMALL FAMILY FARM HOMES THAT.
CHILD EXCLUSION.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO CORRECT
THIS INEQUITY IN THE LAW.
ON THE ON GOING FORWARD BASIS
WHICH WILL PROTECT SMALL FAMILY
FARMERS AND AGRICULTURE OPEN
SPACE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I
WROTE.
OUR STATE TREASURER P. ON A Mà
IS SPONSORING AB.
EIGHT SEVEN TWO HE DISCOVERED
THIS INEQUITY IN OUR TAX LAWS
DURING HER TIME AT THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION.
THEY I HAVE LIKE A DANCE AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS JOHNSON
THE FLOOR IS YOURS YOUR TWO
MINUTES AND WE WELCOME YOU BACK
TO COMMITTEE SIR THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LIKE JOHNSON HEREBY HAVE STATED
A FEW ON A Mà.
THE TREASURE OF THE FORMER CHAIR
OF THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION I
WANT TO CALIFORNIA'S HIGHEST
RANKING FIDUCIARY.
THE SPONSOR AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
AND THINGS THREE MEMBER IDEA
CARRY FOR LEADERSHIP.
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I STATED EARLIER EIGHT AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE IN
THE TAX CODE AND IS NOW THE
DIRECTED TO ADDRESS AN INEQUITY
IN CALIFORNIA'S.
COMPLICATED REASSESSMENT LAWS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
LAS VEGAS RIVAL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK SUCH AS JOHNSON ANOTHER
OPEN IT UP TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME YOU TO THE MICROPHONE.
LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE COME.
FOR XENON WE'RE NOT INTERNET
OVER THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED TO
BE COMPLETED VANCE AT THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO OPPOSE.
WE'RE GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
IF WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR POTENTIAL MOTION.
SO BY SHEER [inaudible]
HELLO -- PROP THIRTEEN HAS BEEN
HERE SINCE.
SEVENTY EIGHT AND THE NUMBER OF
RECALLING PROP THIRTEEN BABIES A
NUMBER OF HOMEOWNERS AT WHAT
THEIR HOMES BEFORE NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS IS GETTING
RATHER SMALL WHAT ABOUT 28% IF
THERE'S AN S..
FESTERING.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE EXACTLY
HOW MANY.
PEOPLE THIS MIGHT AFFECT.
OUR OFFICE HAS CALCULATED BUT I
CAN GET INFORMATION FOR YOU
FOLLOW UP.
RIGHT.
WE ARE AWARE THOUGH THAT.
BEGIN THERE COULD BE A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT.
BUT WE TRY THIS IS GOOD PUBLIC
POLICY BECAUSE THE INTEREST
THREE OTHER PEOPLE THAN THIS
CONCEAL SOLVE THAT ISSUE
[inaudible]
MR JOHNSON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
TO OR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION A MOTION BY THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES PAUL FARMER AND BEING.
EXACTLY THIS BUT IT IS VERY
FRUSTRATING IF YOU CAN'T KEEP IT
OFF FAMILY FARM SO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MANAGER THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH US GOOD TO
SEE YOU THAT DO A ROLL CALL
MISSING CHESTER WIRE HI.
I'M MORE LONG.
IRAQ AYE BELL [inaudible]
RICARDO [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER. FOR IS ZERO
OR TARA WAS IN THE HOUSE AS WELL
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DOES HE THINK MS JOHNSON.
THE GERMAN WE GOT A TWO FOR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT NINE THE NUMBER
ELEVEN THIS IS A SIMILAR BLOOM.
FIRST OF ALL HE'S GOING BE
DISCUSS AN ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS WE'VE BEEN HONORED TO BE
TO WORK WITH THEM ON AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT ELAINE IS COMING BACK FOR
A SECOND.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE MR BLOOM
IF YOU WANT TO KICK US OFF ON A.
B. E. EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR AND YOU
DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK
YOU ALL KEEP MY REMARKS SHORT.
TO AND TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING.
WITH MY STAFF -- WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WANT TO TAKE NOTE
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH THREE
OTHER OFFICES ON THEIR EIGHTY
YOU BILLS TO MANDATE CONFLICTING
PROVISIONS.
AND THAT WOULD BE SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AND TANG ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS AS YOU KNOW OR
NOUGH INNOVATIVE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTION WITH IMMENSE.
POTENTIAL FOR HOUSING CREATION
OF A SINCE WE STARTED REFORM
THESE BILLS A COUPLE YEARS AGO
OR THIS LAW A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO -- WE'VE SEEN GREAT SUCCESS
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF UNITS
THAT HAVE EITHER BEEN BELTRE IN
THE PERMIT ARE IN THE PERMITTING.
PROCESS THERE'S BARRIERS THAT
REMAIN AND AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE
AND THE OTHER -- BILLS SO THAT I
REFERENCED ALL SEEK TO ADDRESS
THE THOSE BARRIERS BY UPDATING
AND CLARIFYING VARIOUS
PROVISIONS. EIGHTY USER
INEXPENSIVE TO BUILD AN
AFFORDABLE ESPECIALLY FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
STUDENTS SENIORS YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS AND THE LIKE AND
THIS BILL WILL HELP EIGHTY USE
REALIZE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
LOUIS MARATHI WHO'S BEEN WITH ME
AT THAT JUST ABOUT EVERY HEARING
I'VE HAD OVER THE LAST -- THREE
YEARS ON EIGHTY IS IS HERE TO
TESTIFY ON THIS.
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
BLOOM UP.
YOUR FOCUS AT LEWIS HAS BEEN A
BUSY GUY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS -- HEY THAT'S WHAT I'M
SAYING AS WELL IN THE WITH THE
YOU KNOW LIKE TO KEEP THEM BUSY
HEY THAT'S RIGHT THOSE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS SIR YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES ON A BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
I THINK -- SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
DID A WONDERFUL JOB RECAPPING
THE BILL.
I JUST LIKE TO I THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS ANALYSIS AND
AMENDMENTS I THINK THEY STRENGTH
IN THE BILL.
I'M AT IS AS THIS COMMITTEE WELL
KNOWS -- ARE A CHEAPER MORE
AFFORDABLE PRODUCTS TO BUILD IT
RESEARCH FROM UC BERKELEY FINDS
THAT. EIGHTY IS ARE OFTEN LOWER
THAN MARKET RATE. FOR TO RENTS.
EVEN WITH IT WITHOUT SUBSIDIES
SO THAT THEY'RE VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR STATES.
SOLUTIONS TO THE ONGOING HOUSING
CRISIS.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT EIGHT EIGHT ONE
OTHERWISE WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
WERE NOW CAN OPEN UP TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD YOU WERE LOOKING FOR
YOUR FIRST AND LAST IN
ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE.
MORNING THIS IS STEPHANIE SHIRKY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
WE REPRESENT SINGLE FAMILY
RENTAL OWNERS WHO OFFER
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT AND WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
WELCOME BACK MORNING RICHARD
LION ON BEHALF OF THE HOME
BUILDERS CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY THIS HAS POSITIVE
BENEFITS BLOWS FROM
AFFORDABILITY AND SUPPLY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A GOOD MORNING.
HI DAVID ON BEHALF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THIS USER.
WE DO A LAST CALL FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT.
CURRENCY NINE WE'RE NOT GONNA
WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
IF YOU PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME
IF YOU MY COMING UP.
THE WELCOMING COMMITTEE.
GIVE US YOUR FIRST AND LAST IN
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING CARA ROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF BURBANK -- SAN
MARCOS.
COUNCIL MEMBERS ACCOUNTS MEMBERS
MAYOR I WILL START BY SAYING
WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF AB USE
EIGHTY YEARS AND WE'RE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKEN COMMITTED MISSISSIPPI THE
ONES RELATED A FIRE SAFETY WE
HAVE TWO REMAINING ISSUES FOR MY
CLIENTS ONE IS THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY THEY FEEL LITTLE.
DEGRADE THE CHARACTER OF THE
COMMUNITIES IF YOU DON'T THEY
LIKE TO REQUIRE AND ROCK
CONSIDER THESE UNITS.
THE SECOND ONE IS A PARKING AND
IT'S A LITTLE BIT ONCE BUT
CONSORTIUM PARKING EVEN THOSE
THIS BILL IS RESTRICTED TE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS DOWN TO
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF TRANSIT IN
A COUPLE OF OTHER VERY SPECIFIC
INSTANCES.
THE ISSUE THAT'S COMING UP FOR
US IS THAT I'M VERY NARROW
STREETS IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT FIRE
TRUCKS ANOTHER FIRE SAFETY AND
OTHER EMERGENCY VEHICLES BEING
ABLE TO GET DOWN THOSE STREETS.
AND IF WE CANNOT REQUIRE ONSITE
PARKING A RESTRICTED ON THAT WE
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
ISSUE IN OUR INABILITY.
IN THOSE VERY SPECIFIC CASES ON
A MINISTER REALLY APPROVED
PERMIT TO BE ABLE TO SAY.
LISTEN THIS IS NOT APPROPRIATE
EVEN WITH SET BACKS WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO GET THE FIRE TRUCKS
NO THE THINGS DOWN BALLOT WROTE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE STILL
REMAIN OPPOSED BUT WE'RE AGAIN
WE'RE VERY THANKFUL FOR THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORDS YOU CAN HAVE YEAH
HANG THERE IF THAT'S OKAY.
I JUST IN CASE OR ANY QUESTIONS.
THAT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA WELCOME ANYONE
OUT TO MAY BE OF HOMES IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR OPPOSITION.
THIS IS GONNA BE LAST CALL.
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
YOU SEE IF ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS YES WELCOME MOTION AYE
SOME VERY BRIEF COMMENTS WOULD
LIKE THERE TO SEE.
WE HAVE ANY COMMENTS PLEASE
MADAM SENATOR FORESHORES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR ANYONE ELSE
WOULD LIKE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
RT OPPOSITION.
LOOK I THINK THAT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THIS AND HAVE THE SOME
MEMBER CLOSE ON THIS.
IS THAT OUT WHILE EIGHTY USE
AREN'T THE SILVER BULLET.
THEY ARE IMPORTANT PART OF
SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
ACROSS THE STATE.
I THINK THAT THERE ARE.
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN
AGGRESSIVE.
IN THE BUILD OUT OF EIGHTY USE.
EACH OF THE THREE BILLS ARE
MOVING FORWARD WOULD ASSIST
COMMUNITIES IN THE CRISIS THAT
WE HAVE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
SOME CONCERN ABOUT PARKING --
WHAT I A HAVE SEEN AT LEAST?
A NEIGHBOR THAT I LIVE IN.
A IN A SMALL COMMUNITY ON THERE
HAVE NOT BEEN THE CHALLENGES.
AND THE WORST FEARS HAVE NOT
BEEN LIVED OUT.
IN UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'RE
REMAIN CONCERNED.
BUT WILL TURN IT OVER. TO THE AD
SOME MEMBER FOR CLOSING COMMENTS
AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS.
I DO APPRECIATE WORKING WITH YOU.
CLOSING COMMENTS PLEASE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
OWNER OCCUPANCY REQUIREMENT IS
ONE OF THE MOST -- IF NOT THE
MOST ONEROUS CHALLENGES TO
BUILDING EIGHTY YEARS AND MANY
OF THE CITY'S -- THAT RICK CHOIR
OWNER OCCUPANCY AROUND THE STATE.
OF WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT -- THAT
REQUIREMENT DETERS BANKS FROM
LENDING FOR RADIO CONSTRUCTION
AND COULD RESULT IN A ACTUALLY
AND UNITS BEING DESTROYED.
A CITIES AROUND THE STATE THAT
DO NOT REQUIRE OWNER OCCUPANCY
HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED THE ISSUES
THAT ARE OUTLINED.
BY THE OPPOSITION HOWEVER -- IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE ADDED A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET -- TO THE BILL EXPRESSLY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF FOR A OF
MONITORING.
WHAT HAPPENS OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS TO SEE IF IT BECOMES A
PROBLEM?
ON THE ISSUE OF PARKING --
FRANKLY ACT I SIMPLY DON'T GET
THE ISSUE.
OF I I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
EMERGENCY VEHICLE ACCESS BUT IF
THERE'S NO PARKING ON THE STREET
IS NO PARKING ON THE STREET.
AN ADDITIONAL CARS PARKING ARE I
MEAN IF THERE WERE TO BE DOUBLE
PARKING THAT WOULD BE A PROBLEM.
BUT THAT'S A PROBLEM IN ANY
COMMUNITY WHERE THERE ARE --
THERE'S HEAVY USE OF THE RETIRED
PARKING.
AND THE YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IN
MY NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE I LIVE IN
SANTA MONICA.
WE HAVE SANTA MONICA COLLEGE
VERY CLOSE BY [inaudible]
PEOPLE.
PARK ON THE STREETS IN THIS AND
THE SPACES YET BILLS.
WELL PLEASE THAT WAS THE CASE
BEFORE PREFERENTIAL PARKING.
BUT THAT WAS NOT AN IMPEDIMENT
TO EMERGENCY VEHICLES THAT WAS A
PARKING ISSUE FOR RESIDENTS.
IN THE CASE OF EIGHTY IS THE
HOUSING IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
IT'S ALL GOING TO BE NEAR
TRANSIT THAT'S GOING TO BE A
BACKUP SYSTEM.
OFFER PEOPLE AND THAT OF THESE
CARS AND FRANKLY WE REALLYNEED
TO INFLUENCE PEOPLE TO UTILIZE
PUBLIC TRANSIT AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO VEHICLES.
THIS WILL HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS WOMEN I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
ALSO THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE.
ANY ISSUES RELATED PARKING AS
WELL SO JUST WANNA CLEAR WITH
THAT.
BUT AGAIN SOME NUMBER THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR HER TYRONE THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU SIR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
I'M MORE A LOT MORE LIKE AYE
BELL -- I KNOW.
THEN I WINNER.
IT ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO VOTE AND
GIVE THE RELEVANT THANK IS
RESCUED YOU SEE IN PLEASE THANK
YOUR CLIENTS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN.
WE HAVE ONE THAT LAST THE BILL
THIS IS THE SECOND OF THE TWO
FOR ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE MR BLOOM
YOU HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL IS WELL. FOR SURE SIR
THANK YOU OF THIS BILL EXTENDS
THE PROPERTY TAX WELFARE
EXEMPTION FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS -- TO INCLUDE
MELARA SPECIAL TAXES.
BELARUS ACT WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO TO ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES.
TO ASSESS A SPECIAL TAX ON TOP
OF FOR A RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY
TAXES TO HELP FUND LOCAL
SERVICES INCLUDING SCHOOLS AND
CITY MAINTENANCE SERVICES.
CURRENTLY WHILE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS ARE EXEMPT FROM
PAYING PROPERTY TAXES UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTIONS.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE SAME
PROJECTS STILL PAY THE MALLORY
SPECIAL TAX WHICH CAN BE AS MUCH
AS A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT.
PER YEAR -- THAT ADDS UP AND SO --
AB SEVENTY FORTY THREE EXAMS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS FROM
THE SPECIAL TAX.
REDUCE THE ANNUAL OPERATING
COSTS OF LOW INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AN INSURER -- OR
HELP ENSURE THE FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING.
THE LEGISLATURE'S PASSED A
NUMBER OF CRUCIAL POLICIES TO
HELP FINANCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND REMOVE BARRIERS AND
CONSTRAINTS TO DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM AT THE
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT THESE
THINGS CUMULATIVELY ALL ADD UP
AND MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE AND TO
TESTIFY.
MARIA MARINO LANCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
THIS YEAR AFTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS BLOOM GOOD
MORNING THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
TO SEE YOU THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MARINO LINE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM REPRESENTING BOTH FOR
PROFIT AND NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
FOCUS ON BUILDING LOW INCOME
HOUSING.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- I DON'T
HAVE MUCH TO ADD TO WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARED TODAY I'M
AS YOU KNOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
REQUIRES VERY COMPLEX FINANCING.
AND ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO --
TO MAKE THE ON GOING OPERATING
EXPENSES LOWER -- WILL HELP US
BUILD MORE UNITS -- MOVING FOR
THIS IS A SMALL BELL BUT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM SHARED AN
IMPORTANT ONE FOR US AND DRIVE
OF TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU BEEN COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP FOR ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
LOOKING FOR FIRST IN LASSEN
ORGANIZATION WELCOME BACK.
HI DAVID BEHALF THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION AND
SUPPORT EXPERTS DAVID.
LAST CALL FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
XENON WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME ANYONE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WE WILL
WELCOME QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION SIR VICE CHAIR WE HAVE A
MOTION CURRENTLY ON THE FLOOR.
THE MOTION TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
THE VICE CHAIR FOR COMMENTS WE
DON'T SEE OPPOSITION.
I JUMP IN.
THANK YOU -- I JUST -- EIGHT
INTEREST WHAT'S THE EFFECTIVE
DATE I I'M SEEING.
AFTER JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY YEAH SO THIS
WOULD NOT APPLY TO SEE IF HE'S
THERE ALREADY CURRENTLY SET UP --
SO IT ONLY BE NEW ORDINANCES
PASS AFTER JANUARY FIRST. TWO
THEN YOU DEVELOPMENTS IN THOSE
DISTRICTS AND THEY WOULD HAVE TO
BE APPROVED IN TOTAL BY EITHER
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OR THE
CITY COUNCIL THAT OVERSEES I'M
VERY NEEDS TO BE OF ALSO
APPROVED BY TWO THIRDS OF THE
VOTERS OF THE DISTRICT.
OKAY.
READ THAT THAT'S HELPFUL BECAUSE
SEE OF THESE. TO HAVE.
THEY'RE KIND OF DIFFERENT THEY
DON'T SEEM TO HAVE A ELECTED
BODY SO YOU'RE SAYING IT IT HAS
TO BE A BALLOT MEASURE YES BUT
OFTEN IT IS THE DISTRICT IS SET
UP IN AN AREA WHERE THERE'S NOT.
DEVELOPMENT YEAH AND SO IT'S THE
OWNER I KNOW THE OF THE ONLY
IDEA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JR THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONVERSATION FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK TURNED OVER TO MR BLOOM TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
HAVE A NICE JOBS IN THE RISKY TO
SEE TODAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE FLOOR.
THANK YOU SIR LOCAL POLICE FIRE
HI MCGUIRE I'M MORE A LOT.
MORE LOCKED AYE BELL HERTZBERG.
ALTHOUGH I NIELSEN.
WE HAVE SOME BIPARTISAN FIST
BUMPS GOING ON RIGHT NOW THANK
YOU SO MUCH AS TO BLOOM.
THANK YOU ALL YOU SEE SIR.
ALL RIGHT.
IRWIN IS IN THE HOUSE WE HAVE AS
A MEMBER IRWIN.
SHE IS FOCUSING AS SHE HAS IN
THE PAST AND WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT SAY THANK YOU TO THE
SENATE WOMAN FOR HER WORK ON ALL
ISSUES AT VETERANS.
HI THIS IS A VETERANS HOUSING
HOMELESS PREVENTION BOND ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS MA'AM WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTING AGAIN THANKS FOR ALL
OF YOUR HARD WORK.
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK EXCEPT
THE RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
EIGHTY SIX NINE FOUR AN AXE THE
VETERANS HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION BOND ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TO AUTHORIZE THE
ISSUANCE OF BONDS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING WAS SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR VETERANS.
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
CALIFORNIANS APPROVED PROP
TWELVE SAYS THAT EARNS BOND
ACTIVE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
FIND MULTI FAMILY.
HOUSING UNITS FOR VETERANS
CREATING THE H. H. P. OVER FOUR
ROUNDS OF FUNDING THE H. H. P.
HAS RICH -- PROVIDED NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED TOTAL
HOUSING UNITS FOR VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THERE IS NOW
ABOUT -- TWO HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION REMAINING IN AS A FOR VH
H. P. AT THE RATE OF SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION PER ROUND THAT
FUNDING WILL RUN OUT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TO GET A BOND ON
THE BALLOT IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
BILL WOULD HAVE TO PASS THIS
YEAR OR WITH AN EMERGENCY.
OF FLAWS NEXT YEAR THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED TWELVE THOUSAND
HOMELESS VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
AND EVEN MORE EXPERIENCING
HOUSING AND SECURITY OR
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
AB SIX NINE FOUR WILL ASSIST%
VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS AND
WHO NEED AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOUSING.
SECURE HOUSING FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES RESPECTFULLY
ASK DRIVE UP TO MY ROOM IS A LOT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY AND FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS WE'RE NOT GONNA
OPEN UP FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME.
LOOKING FOR FIRST IN LASSEN
ORGANIZATION A GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOURISM HAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF VETERANS SERVICE
AGENCIES IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR THE AUTHOR THANKS
HOUSE [inaudible]
MORNING.
AT CHAIR MEMBERS MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING AMERICAN JACK FORM
MERRICK IN THE CHEN.
I AM THAT CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNTY VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
ABOUT.
VETERANS COUNCIL IN MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
ON SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANKS FOR BEING HERE
[inaudible]
MORNING.
THIS IS STEPHANIE SHIRKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT FOR
VETERANS AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SEVENTY THANK BETTER WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE WHO IS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IF YOU CAN PLEASE COME.
FOR WHERE DO A LAST CALL WE'RE
NOT AN OPEN UP TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE OPPOSED OPPOSITION.
CURRENCY NUMBER BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
THIS VICE CHAIR IT'S ALL YOU
NEED OPPOSITION.
BUT AGAIN WE WOMAN IRWIN I WANT --
TO BUT YOU KNOW THAT I'M WEARING
MY WORLD CUP SOCCER TIE.
IN AT NOON TODAY THE NETHERLANDS
PLAYS SWEDEN SO WHERE WHERE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE QUITE A
CONFLICT YOUR WHAT YOU AND I
KNOW.
WE'RE BOTH THE SUPPORTING THE
NETHERLANDS AND MR HER.
I'M SAYING WERE AGHAST.
LET'S FIGURE THAT ONE OKAY THERE
YOU GO EXACTLY ANOTHER LENDS
TODAY FOR SURE.
YEAH THE REAL ISSUE HAPPENS IN
THE FINALS OF THE ANYWAY -- MR
WHEN YOU'RE IN I'VE ALREADY
DISCUSSED TIS MATTER BUT PAGE
FOUR OF THE STAFF REPORT
KENNELLY'S OUT.
YOU KNOW MY CONCERNS AND WHERE
WE ARE IN THE NUMBER OF ON
MEASURES AND AND HOW DO WE PAY
FOR THEM AND THAT'S MY CONCERN
MISTER CHAIR.
I AM.
DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE WITH WHAT
THE BONTA TRYING TO DO SO I I
WANNA MAKE THAT CLEAR ISN'T
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS TODAY
THAT.
MY ONE OF MY BROTHERS IS A
SCHOOL TEACHER SO I'M NOT
AGAINST SCHOOLS I'M I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT'S
ALL PAID.
FOR AND SO FOR THAT REASON I'LL
BE OPPOSED AGAIN.
YOUR TO YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU FOR UNDERSTANDING
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS VICE CHAIR.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL
ITEM NUMBER THREE TO HAVE A
MOTION.
WE HAVE A A MOTION THE MOTION IS
BY CENTER TANTO.
DO PASSES A MANAGER PREPARATIONS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE I'D I'D JUST LIKE
TO SAY IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
OF HOMELESSNESS HOMELESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT NUMBER
SEEMS TO CONTINUE TO INCREASE
BUT IF YOU REALLY DIG DOWN IN
THE NUMBERS THE ONE PLACE.
THAT WE'RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS
IS WITH VETERANS HOUSING.
AND I WOULD SAY WE OWE THEM MORE
THAN ANY OTHER GROUP.
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP
FOR OUR COUNTRY AND PART OF THE
REASON WE'RE ABLE TO REALLY MAKE
A DENT IN THOSE NUMBERS IS VH HP
SO I THINK IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM WHETHER IT GOES ON THE
BALLOT IN TWENTY TWENTY OR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND I
RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU CINNAMON OF 25% OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHRONICLES
POPULATION ARE VETERANS.
A MOST ARE DUAL DIAGNOSIS IS A
CRITICAL BILL UP FOR ONE MOST
IMPORTANT POPULATIONS HERE IN
THE STATES I JUST WANNA SAY
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
ALWAYS GOOD HAVING COMMITTEE
SIGN CHESTER CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ONE HI WHY I'M MORE LOT.
NOBEL.
BURKE -- I KNOW [inaudible]
I WIENER.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE ONE
VOTE FORGET THE ROLE OPEN AND
WHAT I FOCUS ON RIGHT VERY NICE
TO HAVE THE REST TODAY THANK YOU.
MASON GENERAL WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE -- AS WE'RE LOOKING FOR
AUTHORS SO -- HOLD WITH THIS UP
FOR JUST A BIT.
LET'S DO CAN.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GERMAN WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS ARE CONCERNED THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B..
SIXTY FIVE AN ITEM NUMBER FIVE
A. B. SEVEN OH NINE IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE CONSENT.
VICE CHAIR IS IN IT WITH A
MOTION MISSILE INTEREST PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HI.
HI BILL -- AUTO.
I WILL SPEND.
NIELSEN AYE WIENER.
THANK YOU SIR BEFORE WE ARE
CLOSE THAT -- THAT SEE IF --
MISTER BELL WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON
GIVE US A COUPLE MOMENTS AND
THEY CAN TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR IS GOING TO BE.
TALKING ABOUT THE VICE TEARS UP.
FAVORITE ISSUE IN CANNABIS --
THAT YOU'RE AN EXPERT SIR -- ON
AND CANNABIS WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING APPELLATIONS ORGANICS IN
AG COMMITTEE NOT BE RIGHT BACK.
I IS IS WE HAD ON THE DISS RICE
YEAR.
WE'RE NOT GONNA ADD A SINNER
BELL ON IT TOO IS SEVERAL BILLS
CENTRE BELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
OR GOOD MORNING STILL IT'S GOOD
TO SEE SIR WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE A. B. FORTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A TWO ONE VOTE
MISSING CHESTER BELL
[inaudible]
YEAH HI.
THAT ENJOYS A THREE ONE VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
CENTER TARA PLEASE. ONE VOTE
THERE WE GO FOR ONE VOTE WE'RE
GONNA GIVE THE ROLE OPEN.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY SIX
NINETY FOUR THE MOTION IS
CURRENTLY DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
IS LANCASTER CAME PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SALE.
ONLINE. FOR ONE VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THE ROLE OPENS.
WE WELCOME AS A MEMBER LACKEY IF
YOU WANNA COME UP TO THE TABLE
WHAT IS GOING TO AT LEAST A
COUPLE MORE TO GO THROUGH IN THE
MALL TURN RIGHT OVER TO YOU
SIMILAR.
OR ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
SEVEN OH SEVEN THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISSING CHESTER L..
L.. FIVE ZERO VOTE WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS.
THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO CURRENTLY
THIS INTEREST WELL. FIVE ZERO
AND KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
VOTE.
IS IT.
FOUR ZERO OKAY KERN BUT WE'RE AN
ITEM EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHT
ONE DO PASSES IMAGE
APPROPRIATIONS EMOTION CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO MISSING
CHESTER L.. FIVE ZERO WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THAT ROLE OPEN.
FINAL ITEM ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
KERN VOTERS FOUR ZERO MISSING
CHESTER L.. FIVE EIGHT ZERO ZERO
OPEN.
IF YOU CAN GIVE US THIRTY
SECONDS ORGAN BE WITH MR LACKEY
.
LADIES IN GENERAL COMMITTEE WE
WELCOME IS A MEMBER LACKEY.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT BEFORE
SOME NUMBER LACKEY GETS GOING ON
THIS ISSUE AND I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE CINNAMON.
NUMBER ONE I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE NUMBER TWO I
WANNA SAY THANK YOU LISA NUMBER
FOR WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE.
TO WORK THROUGH THIS ISSUE.
HE HAS.
CANDIDLY BEEN A TROOPER HELLO A
THROUGH I AM VERY VERY GRATEFUL
CERVANTES WANTED KNOWLEDGE YOUR
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
I KNOW SOMEONE A KNOWLEDGE OF MS
BROWN WHO IS NEXT TO ME A
CONSULTANT ON THIS BILL WHO'S
BEEN WORKING WITH THE SOME
MEMBERS OFFICE AS WELL.
AS SOME MEMBERS WERE WORKING TO
DO SOME GOOD IN THE STATE -- AND
HE HAS BEEN A WONDERFUL PARTNER
JUST WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOUR HARD WORK.
THE NUMBER I WANTED TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO PRESENT IN
AG COMMITTEE ON YOUR TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU IN TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR AND
AGAIN IF SOMEONE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SERRANO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK AND THERE WAS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF COMMITTEE
WORK AND WE'RE VERY VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT COOPERATION.
AND WE CERTAINLY ACCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS THAT -- THAT YIELD
AND AND I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
TODAY AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
CREATES A VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
FUND TO PROVIDE MORE RESOURCES
TOWARD.
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
ASIDE RATES ARE ON THE RISE
NATIONALLY AND CLEARLY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NEARLY FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
INDIVIDUALS TOOK THEIR OWN LIVES.
THIS IS A PRETTY STAGGERING
INCREASE SAYS TWO THOUSAND ONE
RATES WERE APPROXIMATELY 33%
LOWER.
MANY OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE.
A SUICIDE I'M SORRY MANY OF
THESE WERE ACTUALLY YOUNG PEOPLE
TO THE SITE IS A SECOND AND
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG.
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS.
MORE SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
CRISIS INTERVENTION SERVICES ARE
NEEDED FOR AT RISK POPULATIONS
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN RURAL
LOCATIONS.
THIS SITE IS THE MOST PURPOSE
LET IN RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE.
WHERE THERE ARE FEWER CENTERS
AND SERVICES AVAILABLE?
AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR DRESSES THIS
ISSUE BY CREATING A VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION.
SO THE RESOURCES CAN BE GIVEN TO
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME -- DOCTOR
WECHT DIRECTOR OF THE SUICIDE
PREVENTION A CRISIS SERVICES
WELL SPACE HEALTH IN SACRAMENTO.
AND TOBY EWING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION.
PHOTOS WE WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO
FIRST THE WILL HAVE -- DOCTOR
WORK.
MR CAN MEMBERS THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY -- I'M TO BE
DOING I'M THE DIRECTOR THE
STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THE BILL YOU YOU'VE HEARD THE
DATA AROUND SUICIDE YOU
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA THE COMMISSION IS
ACTUALLY.
TODAY RELEASING A DRAFT OF A
SUICIDE PREVENTION PLAN FOR THE
STATE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT.
OR A LITTLE LESS THAN A YEAR AND
WE'LL SPEND SOME TIME SHARING
THAT AROUND THE STATE TO GET
INPUT AND GUIDANCE SO THAT WE
CAN STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
APPROACH TO SUICIDE PREVENTION.
AND YOU'VE HEARD THE STATISTICS
PARTICULAR FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
I'M TOO MANY OF OUR FOLKS SEE
THIS AS AN OPTION MANY OF OUR
FOLKS STRUGGLED TO GET ACCESS TO
CARE.
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THE THE
PROBLEM IS PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA.
TAX CHECK OFF AS YOU KNOW OUR
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS ARE AS A
STRATEGY THAT THE STATE HAS USED
MANY MANY TIMES I WAS STAFF TO
THIS COMMITTEE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND STAFF THESE BILLS --
THIS IS A VERY WELL RECOGNIZE
STRATEGY -- WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE THIS AS
AN OPTION TO PUT MORE RESOURCES
INTO MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE SO WE CAN DRIVE DOWN
THOSE NUMBERS AND SUPPORT OUR
ABILITY TO SERVE.
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THIS REALLY
TREMENDOUS OPPORTUNITY. FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WITH AB.
NINE EIGHTY FOUR VOLUNTARY TAX
CONTRIBUTION FRIEND.
I'M DOCTOR WITH A DIRECTORS
SUSAN PREVENTION AWHILE SPACE
HOW.
BEEN DOING THIS. FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS I'M ALSO A SURVIVOR OF
SUICIDE LAS.
AN ACCOUNTANT EXPERT ON SUICIDE.
THE RESEARCH DOES SHOW THAT
ACCREDITED CRISIS CENTER SUCH AS
OURS HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
OTHERS LIKE THE HEARST A LOS
ANGELES.
AND WE HAVE A NETWORK OF ELEVEN
CRISIS CENTERS THAT ARE SIMILAR
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THAT THOSE CRISIS CENTERS
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE LIFESAVING
BLANKET OF CARE FOR THOSE IN
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS OR WHO IS
SUICIDAL.
I AM WE HAVE HIGH STANDARDS OF
CARE WERE NATIONALLY ACCREDITED
IS UUALLY IS A CERTIFIED
THROUGH THE NATIONAL LIFELINE.
I WOULD PROVIDE RISK ASSESSMENT
CRISIS INTERVENTION EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT SAFETY PLANNING AND EVEN
FOLLOW UP.
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE AT HIGH
RISK OR IN THE MIDST OF
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
CRISIS CENTERS ARE REALLY VITAL
COMPONENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
BEAVER HEALTH SYSTEM OFTEN
WORKING WITH THE YOUTH AND
ADULTS -- WHO HAVE NOWHERE ELSE
TO TURN?
NO ONE ELSE TO HELP THEM WORK
THE LAST LINE OF DEFENSE
OFTENTIMES FOR FOLKS WERE
SUICIDAL.
AND WE'RE ALSO THE PERFECT FIRST
STEP IN THE MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
A BRIDGE OVER THE GAP IN
SERVICES THAT EXCESS STATEWIDE.
I'M EN INTO THE SAFETY AND THE
CONTINUUM OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AND WE LINK FOLKS TO COMMUNITY
BASED RESOURCES THAT ARE MUCH
NEEDED.
WE ALSO DIVERT.
OUR COLORS FROM OVER BURDENS
RESOURCES LIKE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NINE ONE ONE AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
WHO ALREADY HAVE ENOUGH TO DO
AND DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO BE
INVOLVED AND ARE ALWAYS IN IS
NOT ALWAYS HELPFUL -- CUT
CALIFORNIA CRISIS CENTERS
EXPIRING Là.
EXPERIENCING A LARGE INCREASES
IN CALL VOLUME. 62% AND HIGHER.
I'M JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND THEY'RE OFTEN UNDER
FUNDED.
LET ME SAY WE COULD NEVER HAVE
TOO MUCH SUICIDE PREVENTION
SUPPORT.
STATEWIDE ONGOING SUPPORT OF
THIS NATURE HELPS CRISIS CENTERS
AND DONORS. TO BE MORE ABLE TO
HELP PREVENT IN SUICIDE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS FUNDING WOULD ENABLE US TO
DO MORE.
AND TO REACH MORE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE AT HIGH
RISK OF SUICIDE ALL THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA REALLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WRECKED.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
DO I HAVE ANY I HAVE A MOTION
DRIVE ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK -- AS A AS THE
SENATE THE MEMBER OF THE MALE
HEALTH SERVICES ARE COMMISSION.
LIKE TO THANK GOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY AND THE SUPPORT.
THIS BILL -- TO RAW -- EXPOSURE
TO THE ISSUES FIVE ENGINE THAT'S
THE BEST WAY OF GETTING.
THE NUMBERS DOWN IS TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO A GET EVERYBODY.
IN THE COMMUNITY ACTIVATED AND I
THINK [inaudible]
THIS.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S JUST THE WELL
LICENSE.
THING I THINK IT GOES BEYOND
THAT IN TERMS OF GETTING HE
INFORMATION OUT AND HELPING
PEOPLE SO.
THANK YOU FOR NO THAT'LL SAVE
LIVES I KNOW IT WILL EMPLOYERS
ARE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND YOUR BELT.
OF THE CINNAMON LACKEY I'M I'M
GONNA BE A LITTLE CANTANKEROUS
TODAY I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE FOR
WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY -- I AM
I'M TOTALLY WITH YOU ON THIS
BILL.
BUT AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND I APPRECIATE.
THE ISSUE JUST DOING A LOT OF
WORK IN THE MIDDLE HEALTH SPACE
OF JUST THOUGHT ARTICLE THE
OTHER DAY OUT A PASTOR WHO GIVE
A SERMON ON DEPRESSION.
AND THEN COMMITTED SUICIDE AFTER
THE AFTER THE SERMON.
SO IT'S A BIG ISSUE AND I WANT
TO THANK TO BE DOING FOR THE
BOOK.
OF THE CENTER CANNOT STAND A
VERY START READING IT'S I WANT.
TO THANK YOU THE TEST IS BY
ELLEN SACKS.
SO I DON'T OPPOSE YOUR CONCERN
OR FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING I DID
OF ALL THE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FOR NON MEAL JUST
LAST YEAR.
AND WE SAID THIS YEAR LET'S DO A
MORATORIUM LET'S FIX THE
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION.
SPACE YOU BEEN THERE MISTER
EWING WITH.
INNER WALK.
SO WE WE DID A LOT OF RESEARCH --
YOU KNOW I SPOKE TO TWO HUNDRED
CPA'S.
AT A CONFERENCE I SAID HOW MANY
OF YOU ARE TELLING YOUR CLIENTS
THAT YOU HAVE AN ABILITY. TO DO
A CHECK OFTEN AND AND ADD SOME
DOLLARS.
FROM YOUR REFUND TO CERTAIN
CAUSES.
AND ONLY TWO HANDS WERE RAISED.
AND AND AND SO WE WENT TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD SAID HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY.
USING THESE VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
AND HE SAID ABOUT LESS THAN 2%.
SO SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE
HE TURBO CHARGE.
THIS AREA BECAUSE THE FORM FIVE
FORTY IS NOW FIVE PAGES LONG AND
AT TEN FORTY IS TWO PAGES LONG.
AND SO WE DID A BILL THIS YEAR --
TO TRY AND FIX IT DENOTED THE
JOYS OF CENTER WALT A LITTLE
DIFFERENT BUT LET'S WE SAID
LET'S ALLOW EVERY NONPROFIT
DEBTS RICHARD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
TO BE ABLE TO PUT THEIR NUMBER
OR CODE ON THE FORM FIVE FORTY
M. THE AMOUNT SO THAT WE CAN GET
THE WHOLE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY.
INFORMING THEIR MEMBERS THROUGH
EMAILS WITH YOU KNOW OTHER MEANS
HEY MAKE A CONTRIBUTION ON THE
TEXTURED SO MAYBE WE CAN GET IT
FROM 2% TO FOUR OR FIVE OR 10%
OF PEOPLE.
ARE RESPONDING IN A REGRETFULLY.
THAT WAS HELD UP IN APPROACH SO
I'M.
YOU KNOW ENJOYING THAT CRAZY
WORLD THE THE B. S. OF SUSPENSE
AND JUST YOU KNOW.
LANGUISHING IN PURGATORY AND AND
AND THIS JUST NEEDS TO BE.
NEEDS TO BE FIXED SO I AM GOING
TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
RESURRECT THE BILL AGAIN NEXT
YEAR BUT I PERSONALLY I'M JUST
TRYING TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT
WE'VE GOT TO FIX THE BALI KINDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING IGNORED.
TURBOTAX.
FORGOT TO PUT ALL KINDS IN THEIR
SOFTWARE A COUPLE YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW SO NOTHING NOTHING CAME
TO THE STATE.
SO WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BEEF IT UP AND SO THE CINNAMON
LACKEY BECAUSE I OWE YOU ONE I'M
GONNA VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
AND I'M JOKING BECAUSE HE HIT ME
PRETTY HARD WITH A SOFTBALL A
COUPLE YEARS AGO.
IT WAS A GREAT HIT.
BUT I'M GONNA VOTE NO BECAUSE I
JUST WANNA START MESSAGING TO MY
COLLEAGUES THAT WE'VE GOT TO FIX
THIS ERROR.
WHAT DATA MADAM?
LANCHESTER IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
TAKING ROLE.
WIRE OR LARGE NO.
NO BELL.
WELL I'LL HERTZBERG.
AUTO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I WIENER.
IT HAS A TWO ONE VOTE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR UNDERSTANDING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT VICTIM IS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURNER HORVATH WELCOME.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE SIX ZERO SEVEN ITEM NUMBER.
TEN THANK YOU SO MUCH TO THE
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS HERE I
WANT T THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING.
WITH US ON THIS BILL I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE NOTIFICATION
OF THE GENDER TAX LAW THE
BUSINESS LICENSE THE TIME THE
GENERALIZED.
SORRY AS OF THE TIME THE
BUSINESS LICENSE IS ISSUED AS
WELL AS AT RENEWAL TIME.
AND ENDS LANGUAGE TO THIS BILL
IS A STATE WISE CONCERN AND
THEREFORE APPLIES TO CHARTER
CITIES.
AND THE THIRD AMENDMENT IS TO
REQUIRE THE NOTICE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
BE DEVELOPED BY OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY OF THE LOCAL AGENCY
SHOULD COMPLY BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AB SIXTY NO
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ISSUE A NOTICE. TO A
BUSINESS WITH INFORMATION ABOUT
THE GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT -- AT
THE TIME THE BUSINESS RECEIVED
AS LICENSE AND AT THE TIME OF
RENEWAL.
THE BUSINESS WITH THE BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO DEVELOP A
PAMPHLET.
OR OTHER INFORMATIONAL RICHER
MATERIALS EXPLAINING THE
BUSINESSES RIGHTS AND
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THIS ACT.
AND UNDER CURRENT LAW THE JENNER
TAX REFLECTS PROHIBITS.
BUSINESSES FROM CHARGING
DIFFERENT PRICES FOR DIFFERENT
SERVICES BASIC UPON GENDER.
THE CHALLENGES THAT MANY
BUSINESSES EXPRESS SPECIALLY
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE NOT AWARE
OF THIS LAW THAT THIS LAW EVEN
EXIST AND I'LL GET EXAMPLE FROM
MY OWN SMALL BUSINESS.
I AM HAVE A BUSINESS THAT DESIGN
CENTURY FROM THE CLOTHING FOR
LITTLE GIRLS.
I WOULD DO LITTLE BOYS CLOTHING
AS WELL BUT THEY'RE NOT AS FUN
TO STOP.
SO I ONLY THE LITTLE GIRL
CLOSING BUT SHOULD I HAVE DONE
BOTH I PROBABLY NOT KNOWING
ABOUT THE SLOW MAY HAVE CHARGE
DIFFERENT PRICES FOR GIRLS AND
BOYS CLOTHES BECAUSE BOYS HAVE
LOWER MARKET PRICE POINT THAN
GIRLS.
OUR LAW SAYS YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
AND I WOULDN'T HAVE KNOWN THAT
IS A SMALL BUSINESS.
SO THIS IS WHY THIS IS
PERSONALLY AT IMPORTANT BILL TO
ME AND BY REQUIRING
CERTIFICATION OF ABOUT THE
GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT.
AT THE TIME OF THE TREATING THE
LICENSE.
AB SIXTY AS A MEMBER WE INCREASE
BUSINESSES AWARENESS OF THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE LAW AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY PREVENT VERY
VERY COSTLY FEES.
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
JENNER TAX REPEAL ACT WHICH
COULD REALLY DEVASTATE A SMALL
BUSINESS ESPECIALLY ONE JUST
STARTING OUT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY IN WITH ME I HAVE
LEYVA SILVERTHORNE FROM THE CAL
CHAMBER THE SPONSOR OF THE SPELL.
SB CAN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS SALINAS OVER THERE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT AB.
SIXTEEN OH SEVEN THIS BILL
CURRENTLY AFTER AMENDMENTS
REQUIRES THAT LOCAL LOCALITIES
ISSUING PERMITS ISSUED NOTICES
OF THE DINNER TAX REPEAL ACT IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES WHICH IS VERY
HELPFUL CONSIDERING OUR DIVERSE
BUSINESS CLIMATE IN CALIFORNIA --
IT ALSO.
DEALS WITH ISSUES THAT HAVE COME
UP RECENTLY AS POINTED OUT BY
THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES.
BUSINESSES WERE RECENTLY
TARGETED BECAUSE OF THEIR
PERCEIVED NATIONALITY OR RACE OR
ETHNICITY FORM UNFAIR AND
FRIVOLOUS BUSINESS PRACTICES.
THERE WAS IT IF YOU INSTANCES OF
SOME ATTORNEYS TARGETING THESE
BUSINESSES.
BECAUSE OF THE GENDER TAX
PRICING ISSUE SO THIS BILL
REQUIRING MULTIPLE LANGUAGES AND
PROVIDING ADVANCE NOTICE TO THE
ADVANCE NOTICE.
TO BUSINESSES OF THE IMPACTS OF
THE GENDER TAX REPEAL.
WILL HELP BUSINESSES COMPLY AND
PREVENT THAT NEED LISTEN
FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION AND I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ALTHOUGH
THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO SUBMIT
LETTERS OF SUPPORT IN TIME FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON ANALYSIS THIS
BILL IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
THIRTEEN LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE.
THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES IN THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION.
SO FOR THESE REASONS OTHERS WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONSORED SUPPORT
AB.
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I ONLY HAVE.
ONE AND THAT IS.
SEEN AS WITH THE EIGHTY A REBELS
LAWSUIT TERM FOR RE DOING
ANYTHING OR THE TO GO AFTER THE
LAW FIRMS THAT DO.
THIS KIND OF STUFF AS WELL AS WE
HAVE IT IS -- ADEQUATE
LEGISLATION TO STOP THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR AND WE WE WE WE YOU HAD
A SAMPLE OF A CASE.
IN A REPORT INTO.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT I'M JUST
WONDERING.
IT WOULD ARE YOU AWARE OF
ANYTHING ELSE WE'VE DONE THAT.
STOP THE NONSENSE I THINK FOR
FOR A FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
HELPING BUSINESSES COMPLY FROM
THE OUTSET.
IS MUCH MORE OF PACKED FULL OF
THAT BECAUSE THEN BUSINESSES
WON'T BE TARGETED WITH THESE
LAWSUIT -- I THINK LAKE AND
SPEAK TO THE WATER THERE'S NO
CURRENT BILL PENDING TO DEAL
WITH THE SPECIFIC ISSUE BUT AS
FAR AS THE LAWYERS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THAT PARTICULAR THEY
WERE AGAIN HOLD THE FOR THE
COURT THEY WERE CHARGED WITH
EXTORTION.
AND DIFFERENT CAUSES OF ACTION
SO WE ARE THE STATE HAS BEEN
PURSUING THESE -- BAD ACTORS BUT
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTS
OUT THAT WAY TO PREVENT THIS IS
TO ALLOW THESE BUSINESSES TO
HAVE ADVANCE NOTIFICATION SO
THAT THEY KNOW TO PRICE THEIR
GOODS APPROPRIATELY SO THAT THEY
CAN'T BE TARGETED UNFAIRLY.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THE CHAIR BACK IN THIS
IS THE MOST CRITICAL PART OF THE
WHOLE PROCESS.
BACK OVER TO HIM.
MY GUESS THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
VICE CHAIR I DO APOLOGIZE AS A
MEMBER I APOLOGIZE NOT BEING
HEROES.
OF AN ACT -- AT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
IS IN GERMAN COMMITTED WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
A MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- CINNAMON
REJECT CLOSE PLEASE.
YES I AM THIS IS IMPORTANT A
SMALL BUSINESS BILL IT WILL
PREVENT -- UNNECESSARY FINES
BECAUSE IT WILL LET BUSINESSES
COMPLY WITH THE ACT AND HAVE
THAT NOTIFICATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOU SO MUCH JUST A NUMBER.
THANK YOU SIR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WIRED HIGH WIRE
I'M MORE LONG.
WALK AYE BELL.
WELL I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
THE NINE WIENER.
BIPARTISAN FIST PUMP FOR IS HERE
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE NUMBER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE ARE ON A SEARCH FOR SIMILAR
ISSUE -- HE'S SHARON AND DAD ALL
RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING DEBT.
WORK ON GETTING HIM FROM THAT
COMMITTEE CRIED OUT.
WE ARE PRESENT ON ALL ISSUES --
PUBLIC MAKING.
WE'RE GONNA ASCA THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE.
CENTER NIELSEN HOW HE'S DOING
ANYTHING NEW.
MEETING INTERESTING AS WE ARE
WAITING.
FOR THE RIVER.
TO THIS IS SENATOR.
A GOOD EFFORT JOINT LEAH MANY OF
US TO SOLVE THE FIRE PROBLEMS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S ENCOURAGING
THERE IS AT LEAST SOME HOPE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE A BI PARTISAN
EFFORT VERY FOCUSED ON THAT THE
WHEN ASKED I MARIE S. INNER BELL
THE SAME QUESTION IS WE ARE
WAITING FOR THE SEMINAR.
WHAT HE DOING FOR THE FOURTH OF
JULY -- CENTER NIELSEN.
THANK YOU.
SACRAMENTO RIVER OUR HOME RIGHT
ACROSS FROM THE ELKS CLUB WHERE
THEY LAUNCH ALL THE FIREWORKS.
RIGHT AT GROUND ZERO FOR THE
LAUNCHING IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT
WOW THAT IS FANTASTIC ARE YOU A
BARBECUE WOULD BE DOING.
YEAH WE DO A LITTLE FAMILY
BARBECUE AND THEN WE GET SET OUT
THERE ON THE BACK OF THE RIVER
AND LOOK AT THE FIREWORKS.
IS A PRETTY GOOD SHOW.
YEAH THEY DO A GREAT JOB THEN
THE SUPPORT TO THIS LOCATION
YOU'RE NOT RIGHT AT IT.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT ACROSS THE
RIVER.
AND THEN OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE
SPARKLE OF THOSE.
WHITES AS A BLOW UP IN THE IN
THE SKY YEAH ARTICLE ON THE ON
THE RIVER.
I'LL VERY COOL SO HOW LONG HAVE
YOU BEEN DOING THAT AND WERE YOU
THERE PRIOR TO THEM LUNCH IN THE
SHOW OR DID.
NO NO NO WE WE HAD ABOUT FIVE
YEARS.
THAT IS FANTASTIC.
WITH A GOOD LOCATION. OH MY GOSH
RIGHT IN THE PRIME I LOVE IT.
I THINK CENTER CENTER BELL WE
GOT A A BIG HOLIDAY COMING UP
TOMORROW -- TELL US WHAT'S SO
WHAT'S IN THE PLANS SAN JOSE.
THERE WAS A HAS A BIG A RED
WHITE AND BLUE PARADE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE FUN WITH
THE PARADE AND ARE YOU CAN BE IN
THE PARADE.
SIR LEON.
I THINK I'M AN ANTI CAR ALL THAT
SWEET -- HOPE IT'S A CONVERTIBLE
HEY THERE YOU GO SO TO BE A LOT
OF FUN AND WE'RE GONNA --
CELEBRATE WITH MY FAMILY.
TALK ABOUT MY SIX GREAT
GRANDFATHER.
WHO WAS A -- WE'RE GRADE MAJOR
IN THE REVOLUTIONARY.
WAR MARYLAND LINE REALLY AT THIS
TIME A AND JULY FOURTH SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX HE WAS MARCHING.
WITH HIS REGIMENT TO OF NEW YORK.
BY THE BRITISH.
WHILE [inaudible]
GOOD A WE'RE GONNA -- WE ALWAYS
CELEBRATE THE FOURTH OF JULY AND
THOSE AT THE FOUGHT FOR FREEDOM.
WITH THE AVAILABLE OR WHAT IT
WAS THAT IS BILL.
WOW.
YOU WILL MARCH INTO NEW YORK
WITH THE MARYLAND REGIMENTS
REALLY.
THE SUPPORT GEORGE WASHINGTON
WHEN THE RIGHT BEFORE THE
BRITISH LANDED IN NEW YORK.
THAT IS IMPRESSIVE.
WHY ARE YOU DOING FIREWORKS
TOMORROW NIGHT WILL BE DOING?
WE DO NOT DO FIREWORKS IN SAN
JOSE THERE ARE YOU LEGAL.
IN OUR CITY AND WE DO NOT
CONDONE FIREWORKS SO PLEASE DO
NOT -- USE FIREWORKS IN SAN JOSE.
WELL I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
MAKE A STOP IN FAIRFIELD GET
YOUR OWN STASH.
NO I'M NOT GOING TO BUY MY FOR
WORK SO I DO NOT ALL RIGHT.
I DO NOT CONDONE FIRE WORDS.
I PREFERRED WE HAVE SO MANY --
BOTTLE ROCKET FIRES AND SOUND AS
A THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS VERY BUSY.
WITH ILLEGAL FIREWORKS --
HITTING THE ROOFS OF PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY SHOULD OFF THE BALL
ROCKETS SO?
WE WANT OUR WE WANT TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE AND NOT USE ILLEGAL
FIREWORKS IN OUR IN OUR BIG
CITIES SO.
WE WE TRY TO HELP THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
OUR FIREFIGHTERS NEED A NEED A
BREAK ON THE FOURTH OF JULY --
AND WE ASK CENTER NIELSEN --
WHAT IS ON THE MENU FOR HIS
FOURTH OF JULY SO SMALL BARBECUE --
WITH CENTER NIELSEN.
AT WHAT'S ON THE MENU TOMORROW
NIGHT AT THE CASA DE BELL
[inaudible]
OF I DON'T KNOW BUT I WE TOLD
WHAT TO COOK HEY THERE YOU GO.
I LIKE IT.
WELL.
YOU'RE THE CHOCOLATE.
HI WE HAVE THE TWO PARADES
TOMORROW SO WE'RE DOING THAT THE
BRADY IN NEVADA WILL.
I AND THE WHOLE BUNCH OF US ARE
WALKING IN THAT AND WE THIS IS
FOR THE JULY IS REALLY EXCITING
FOR THE ENTIRE TEAM BECAUSE WE
GET INTO A CAR -- WE BREAK THE
SPEED LIMIT TO GET DOWN TO COURT
MADERA.
BECAUSE IT STARTS TO HALF HOUR
AFTER WE GET BACK. TO THE INTO
NEVADA THERE WAS REALLY HAPPY.
EXCITED WHAT'S THAT.
NO SO WE'RE GONNA DO THE NEVADO
PARADED TEN AM TOMORROW MORNING
AND THEN IT'S THE WORLD'S
LONGEST PARADE -- FIVE MILES
CORD MADERA IN LARKSPUR.
SO -- IN BY THE TIME IT INTO
EVERYBODY'S IN A GREAT MOOD.
HEY BEING SARCASTIC.
BUT NO IT'S COULD BE GREAT AND
AS WE'RE LOOKING FOR THAT AND
THEN WE HAVEN'T -- SOME FOLKS
OVER AND WE ARE BERMAN SOME
VEGGIE PATTIES IN TURKEY BURGERS
TOMORROW NIGHT.
A GREAT BLACK BEAN BURGERS.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
THING IS IS THAT THERE'S NO WAY
IN HELL I MEET A BLACK BEAN
BURGER [inaudible]
GO.
A VEGGIE BURGER I LIKE THE OTHER
BLACK BEAN IT'S GOOD.
YEAH AND YOU GET THE WAS A
TRADER JOE'S -- POSSIBLE BURGER
NOW.
AND I AM NOT SURE ABOUT THE
IMPOSSIBLE.
I'M A VEGETARIAN SO.
I THINK I'M THE ONLY SENATOR IS
A VEGETARIAN.
AND I DON'T THINK SHE IS NOT I'M
A VEGETARIAN YES.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WE ARE OF
AUTHORS SO -- LET'S HOPE OF
FLIPPING AUTHOR GETS HERE QUICK.
SO -- WE'RE GOING TO CHECK IN
ONLINE DAVID CHIU ON ALL ISSUES
OF PUBLIC BANKING AND WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU SIR NIELSEN
ANY OTHER ITEMS YOU WOULD LIKE
TO BE ABLE.
TO I MEAN ON ALL RIGHT WE'LL BE
RIGHT BACK WITH YOU IN WILL
FIGURE OUT WHERE MR CHOOSE AT
I
TOTALLY AGREE LAYS IN GENERAL.
THE MAN THE MYTH THE LEGEND FROM
THE GOLDEN GATE HE IS HERE IN
READY TO ROLL.
MR TO IS THAT YOU KNOW WE WERE --
TALKING WITH -- CENTER NIELSEN
ABOUT FOR THE JOY PLANS --
CENTER BELL BUT HIS FOURTH OF
JULY PLANS AT THEIR NIELSEN IS --
PLACES RIGHT THEIR LIVES ON THE
SACRAMENTO'S WILL BE WATCHING
FIREWORKS -- CENTRE BELL IS
HOARDING ILLEGAL FIREWORKS FROM
FAIRFIELD TO BRING HIM INTO SAN
JOSE'S WHAT HE CONFESS.
HE'S HE'S BRINGING IN A STASH.
TELL US ABOUT THE END OF IN
PARADES AS WELL AS A MEMBER.
MY WIFE AND I ARE DEBATING
WHETHER TO EXPOSE OUR THREE YEAR
OLD SON TO THE IDEA OF FIREWORKS
WERE VOTING THIS TIME NOT TO SO
WE'RE NOT SURE WE'RE GOING TO DO.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE WE GO BUT WE
ARE GOING TO ENJOY BARBECUE HOW
ARE YOU REALLY YES THAT'S GREAT.
THE END AS A MEMBER WHAT ARE THE
PLANS ON THE FOR THE JULY.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO BARBECUE AT
OUR HOUSE AND THEN -- HOGAN IT
WOULD PROBABLY WATCH SOME
FIREWORKS SHOW.
HOW MANY I MEAN THERE HAS TO BE
HOW MANY IN LA?
WELL I TRIED I PLAY SAY IN THE
COMMUNITY THAT I LIVE IN THE PIE
BE ABOUT. SEVEN FOR BACKYARDS --
YEAH OR ON THE STREETS AND THEN --
THEY'LL BE ONE OFFICIAL ONE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES A VERY COOL
I LIKE IT.
GOOD STUFF.
WELL LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE
HAVE THE DYNAMIC DUO HERE WITH
US WE HAVE THE SAME NUMBER CHU
IS WELL SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO.
THIS ISSUE IS FOCUS ON PUBLIC
BANGS THIS IS AB EIGHT FIFTY
SEVEN SOME NUMBER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND APPRECIATE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE MEMONS I WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT IN PARTICULAR TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN.
AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR DEEP
ENGAGEMENT WITH MY OFFICE AND
OUR COALITION.
PARTICULARLY ON AN ISSUE THAT WE
COMMITTED TO RESOLVE IN SENATE
BANKING COMMITTEE TO INCLUDE A
REQUIREMENT OF BALLOT BOX
APPROVAL FOR VOTERS FOR GENERAL
LOST CITIES INCLUDING THOSE
CITIES THAT ALSO ENTER INTO A
GPA.
BUT DOING THAT WITHOUT
UNDERMINING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY OF CHARTER CITIES TO
GOVERN THEIR OWN AFFAIRS.
AT THIS MOMENT THE LARGEST BANKS
IN AMERICA ON WALL STREET HOLD
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
CALIFORNIA STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
FUNDING THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE
LOCAL CONTROL OVER TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE INVESTED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR AND THIS
BILL DOES NOT ESTABLISH A PUBLIC
BANK IT SIMPLY ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO CHARTER A PUBLIC BANK.
WHICH WOULD BE A LONG MULTI YEAR
PROCESS WITH MANY REGULATORY
HURDLES.
WE CRAFTED A BILL TO ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC BANKING ASSETS ARE
PROPERLY SAFEGUARDED.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
COMPLIANCE WITH ALL REQUIREMENTS
OF FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS LAW
AND BANKING LAW WITH REPORTING
AND TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS.
ARE BILL REQUIRES A PUBLIC BANKS
KEEP THE SAME COLLATERAL
REQUIREMENTS AS PRIVATE BANKS TO
MAIN.
MAINTAIN FDIC DEPOSIT INSURANCE
TO CONDUCT FEASIBILITY STUDIES
AND TO PROVE BUSINESS PLANS THAT
ANALYZE COSTS.
CAPITAL REQUIREMENTS FINANCIAL
PROJECTIONS AND LEGALITY WHEN
APPLYING FOR A OUR BILL WOULD
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO BE
OF A CERTAIN SIZE BEFORE
APPLYING FOR BANKING CHARTER.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO EXCLUDE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND REQUIRE
COUNTIES UNDER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS TO
FORM A GPA.
WE ALSO CRAFTED A BILL TO
SUPPORT LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY ENCOURAGES PUBLIC
BANKS WHEREVER POSSIBLE TO
pINSTITUTIONS CREDIT UNIONS
COMMUNITY BANKS ETCETERA. TO
CONDUCT RETAIL SERVICES WITH
THOSE LOCAL INSTITUTIONS THIS IS
MODELED AFTER THE PUBLIC BANK OF
NORTH DAKOTA.
WHICH HAS SUCCESSFULLY PARTNERED
WITH THOSE SORTS OF INSTITUTIONS
OF FOR PROFIT RETURNS FOR MANY
YEARS SO WITH THAT.
ELECTED.
TRULY BEEN A JOINT AUTHOR AND
EVERY -- IN EVERY MEANING OF
THAT TERM MR SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I MISS HIM AND
I APOLOGIZE AND HAVE TO GO VOTE
IN EDUCATION I'LL BE RIGHT BACK
BUT BEFORE I DO I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO BOTH. TEN OVER
TO AS WELL AS A MEMBER SANTIAGO
FOR THEIR ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE.
FOR THEIR WORK IN THEIR DEEP
ENGAGEMENT WE ARE TRULY
APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR EFFORTS I
IN THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR AND
AGAIN WE'RE ALWAYS GRATEFUL TO
WORK WTH YOU.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR HIM PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
THIS IS A DIFFICULT ISSUE TO
UNDERSTAND IT IS FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME.
I IN MY OWN WORDS NOT YOURS I
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING A CHAMPION
OF PUSHING NEW PER AUGUSTA BOLD
IDEAS -- PARTICULARLY ONE LIKE
THIS AND FOR HELPING US TO
CLARIFY THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
CHARTER SEE BEING ABLE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
AND GENERAL LAW CITY WOULD BE
THE ONE THAT WOULD.
ACTUALLY GO THROUGH THE BALLOT
MEASURE IT AND IF THERE'S ANY
REQUIRED -- CLARIFYING LANGUAGE
I'M I'M SURE YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH US ON THAT PIECE IN --
BUT ONE THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
LET ME JUST SORT OF I THINK THIS
IS FAIR IS POLICY PROPOSAL.
I KNOW THE VERY MANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHEN WE FIRST STARTED BUT
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
IT'S GOT TO BE FDIC INSURED.
I EIGHTY REQUIRES A RIGOROUS --
FEASIBILITY STUDY ARE YOU STILL
HAVE TO GO THE DEPARTMENT TO DO
YOU HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL FEDERAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS TO BE ABLE
TO ESTABLISH A A PUBLIC BANK.
I THINK WE'LL KNOW WHY WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE THE OLD WAY OF
BANKING IS NOT WORKING.
I AM ONE ALLOW MONTHS POLITIES
TO SET UP A PUBLIC BANK FOR A
PUBLIC GOOD IT'S VERY BASIC
CONCEPT IT'S A NEW CONCEPT AT
THE END OF THE DAY IT'S A PUBLIC
BANG FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD. FOR
OUR DOLLARS ARE A COULD BE
INVESTED AYE TOWARDS DOING.
A GOOD OUR COMMUNITIES AS
OPPOSED -- TO AS AS OPPOSED --
TO HELPING WALL STREET THANK YOU.
TO THE COMMITTEE A STAFF --
MISTER CHAIR IN THE MEMBERS WHO
ARE HERE I WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED
HOW AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
EYE BUT WHEN THAT TIME COMES
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. FOR MORE LIKE MEMBERS
MIKE MONEGAN ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
BREED AND THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
HI THE END OF US BECAUSE WITH
HELP FOM TO TO JUSTICE ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
REALLY JORDAN WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'M NANCY PRICE A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BANKING
ALLIANCE I'M ALSO.
A CO CHAIR OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
DEMOCRACY AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION AND ON THE BOARD OF
THE WOMEN'S INTERNATIONAL LEAGUE
FOR PEACE AND FREEDOM U. S.
SECTION.
THAT HAVE LARGE MEMBERSHIP IN
THE STATE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
YOUR MEMBERS MORE TALK ON THE
HAVE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SO OUR OUR WITNESSES DIDN'T
PRESENT BEFORE THE OTHER SO
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IF THAT'S
OKAY.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER BASHIR DOCTOR
CHAU WHO TRUE YOU BET.
THANK YOU -- TWO MINUTES EACH
AND IN OUR COMMITTEE.
OF THANK YOU OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR ARE BILL AND
THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
JUNE SANTIAGO FOR AUTHORING THIS
THIS BILL TO GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CONTROL OVER THEIR
OWN FINANCES.
HI MY NAME IS SYLVIA CHI AND I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC BANKING ALLIANCE.
OUR ALLIANCE REPRESENTS EVERYDAY
PEOPLE FROM TEN CITIES AND
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE FROM
EUREKA TO SAN DIEGO.
IN ADDITION WE ARE PROUD TO GAIN
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL FROM OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENTING
COMMUNITIES ORGANIZED LABOR.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE ADVOCATES IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN HAS ALSO
BEEN ENDORSED BY THREE OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST CITIES LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND
OAKLAND AS WELL AS RICHMOND SAN
DIEGO SANTA CRUZ.
LONG BEACH HUNTINGTON PARK
BERKELEY EUREKA IN WATSONVILLE
AS WELL SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
AFTER THIS LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS OUR COMMUNITY IS CLEAR
NEED FOR AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
WALL STREET MEGA BANKS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY THE PRIMARY PROVIDERS
OF DEPOSITORY SERVICES. FOR
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND COUNTIES.
OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
PASSED RESOLUTIONS IN SUPPORT OF
THE STANDING ROCK SIOUX AND
AGAINST THE WALL STREET FINANCE
DAKOTA ACCESS PIPELINE.
AND OTHER NEW FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE ADOPTED SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENT POLICIES
AND ORDINANCES AGAINST
CONTRACTING WITH COMPANIES THAT
DO NOT PAY THEIR WORKERS A
LIVING WAGE.
OR STEAL FROM THEIR WORKERS.
GET CITIES KEEP HAVING TO WAIVE
THESE POLICIES AND LAWS TO AWARD
LUCRATIVE CONTRACTS TO THESE
BANKS BECAUSE THERE ARE NO OTHER
OPTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN
JOSE'S CONTRACT FOR BANKING
SERVICES WAS UP FOR RENEWAL IN
MARCH.
ALL OF THE BANKS BIG ENOUGH TO
HANDLE THEIR DEPOSITS WERE NOT
COMPLIANT WITH THE CITY'S POLICY
AGAINST WORKING WITH COMPANIES
WITH MULTIPLE WHICH THAT
VIOLATIONS.
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
THE WINNING BID WENT TO CHASE
WHICHHAD INCURRED A RECORD OF
OVER TWENTY WAIT AN HOUR
VIOLATIONS.
INCURRING OVER ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FINES.
LIKEWISE LAST EAR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES HAD NO CHOICE BUT TO
EXTEND HIS CONTRACT WITH WELLS
FARGO.
DESPITE ITS UNSATISFACTORY NEEDS
TO IMPROVE RATING ATTRIBUTED TO
THEIR IT DISCRIMINATORY IN A
LEGAL CREDIT PRACTICES RESULTING
IN SIGNIFICANT HARM TO CONSUMERS.
IN MY CITY OF OAKLAND OR CITY
COUNCIL HAD TO WAIVE OUR LIVING
WAGE ORDINANCE IN ORDER TO
CONTRACT WITH THE UNION BANK.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEED A WAY
TO BANK OUR PUBLIC DOLLARS THAT
IS SAFE AND DOES NOT ACTIVELY
BREAK THE LAW AND HARM OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
OUR COMMUNITIES ALSO NEED
INVESTMENTS THAT CENTERS
COMMUNITIES NOT PROFITS.
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR
WITH THE CRISIS IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT IS WREAKING HAVOC
ACROSS THE STATE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
IN LOS ANGELES ORANGE RIVERSIDE
AND SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES
THERE'S A SHORTFALL OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
UNITS.
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME RENTERS.
AND THAT NUMBER IS ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION UNITS FOR THE WHOLE
STATE.
BANKS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS CAN HELP MEET THAT UNMET
NEED.
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN CREATES A
FRAMEWORK SO THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES CAN APPLY TO THE STATE
BANKING REGULATOR THE DPO FOR
LICENSED ESTABLISH THEIR OWN
BANK.
UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST FIRST CONDUCTS
AND VOTE TO APPROVE A STUDY
ADDRESSING THE VIABILITY AND
GOVERNANCE OF THE PUBLIC BANK.
IN SOME CASES VOTERS MUST ALSO
VOTE ON THE STUDY.
BEFORE THEY EVEN SUBMIT AN
APPLICATION TO THE GPO THE
PROFESSIONALS AT DPO FDIC AND
THE FEDERAL RESERVE WILL
THOROUGHLY SCRUTINIZED EACH.
EACH SUCH APPLICATION A SPECIAL
CONCERN FOR POLITICAL
INTERFERENCE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO OVERSEE AND REGULATE ANY
APPROVED BANK.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
COLLATERAL NATION REQUIREMENTS
OR COUNTY TREASURER TO DO SHE OR
YOU DO YOU SHOULD MAKE PRUDENT
INVESTMENTS.
PUBLIC DOLLARS WILL BE SAFE AND
PUBLIC BANKS TO DO THE STRONG
SAFEGUARDS APPLICABLES TO ALL
BANKS HOLDING PUBLIC DEPOSITS.
AND THE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
BUILT INTO THIS BILL.
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NEED A WAY
TO RESPONSIBLY BANK AN INVESTOR
PUBLIC DOLLARS.
AN EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN IS
THE COMMON SENSE SOLUTION WE
NEED THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
YOUR BILL AND WE URGE YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATORS THANK YOU
COMMITTING THANK YOU. TO THE
BILL'S SPONSORS OF MY NAME'S
CHRIS PADLOCK -- I'M HERE IN
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BANKING ALLIANCE AND FRIENDS OF
PUBLIC BANKING IN SANTA ROSA.
I'M A CERTIFIED GOVERNMENT
FINANCE OFFICER WITH OVER TWENTY
YEARS SERVING AS A FINANCE
MANAGER FOR PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
ENTITIES -- CURRENTLY THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR VALLEY
THEM IN WATER DISTRICT.
OVER IN THE BEAUTIFUL VALLEY OF
CINEMA -- I LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
THAT SERVER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FEEL
PRESSURE TO MAXIMISE UTILITY OF
PUBLIC FUNDS.
WE SIT IN PUBLIC MEETINGS WHERE
WE FEEL THE PRESSURE TO KEEP
TAXES AND RATES LOW ALL AT THE
SAME TIME KEEPING THE SERVICES
THE COMMUNITY EXPECTS.
ROADS PAVED WATER FLOWING AND
ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY COMPLY WITH
THE VARIOUS -- RECORD --
INVESTMENT POLICIES FOR PUBLIC
FUNDS -- DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FIRESTORM OUR DISTRICT
WAS HEAVILY AFFECTED BY THE
FIRES -- WE ALSO.
LEARNED THAT WE ALL HAD A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
WORK TO DO AS A RESULT OF THE
THE PRESSURES FROM THAT FIRE
STORM -- WE'RE LOOKING AT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN INVESTMENTS -- AND AS A
PUBLIC FINANCE OFFICER WHEN I GO
OUT AND LOOK AT PROJECTING THOSE
PROJECTS UNDER FINANCING THAT'S
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE.
THE EFFECT IS DONE BASICALLY
DOUBLING THE BUT THE COST OF
THOSE PROJECTS TO THE TAX.
PAIRS OVERTIME.
UNDER THE PUBLIC MAKING MODEL
THAT WE SEE EN IN THIS BILL IS
MODELED AFTER IN NORTH DAKOTA
MANY OF THIS FINANCING COSTS CAN
BE CUT IN HALF [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
WHEN?
DEPOSITING A PUBLIC FUNDS I SEE
A PUBLIC BANK IS ONE MORE SAFE
PLACE TO PUT OUR PUBLIC FUNDS
LIKE MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
INVESTMENT POLICIES HAVE MANY
RESTRICTIONS ON WHERE AND HOW WE
CAN DEPOSIT ANYONE FINANCED.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAVE
INVESTMENT POLICIES THAT
REQUIRES -- TO LOOK AND EVALUATE
THOSE INSTITUTIONS BASED ON
THEIR BEHAVIOR.
WHICH SEVERELY LIMITS US ARE A
LOT OF FORCES US TO WAIVE SOME
OF THOSE REQUIREMENTS THE THIRTY
SECONDS THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR.
ANYWAY IN AN IRISH YOU'RE EITHER
ON THIS -- ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SEE HEREWE DID THIS
LITTLE BACKWARDS WE DID ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE IN
OPPOSITION FIRST AND THEN WE HAD
OUR WITNESSES SO WE'VE.
SO I TRY IN SUPPORT SAID SO
WE'RE WE'RE READY FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND FOUR THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL.
WELCOME THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSE
PROGRAM A PRIMARY WITNESS.
AS WELL AS A SECONDARY.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE A KICK ****
OFF PERSON LAST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION?
I WANT TO GO FIRST A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KAREN LYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURER'S AND TAX COLLECTORS.
OUR OPPOSITION IS A REALLY
ROOTED IN THE FACT THAT THERE'S
pAVAILABLE TO PUT INTO A PUBLIC
BANK SO IT'S CRAZINESS.
FALSE PROMISE THAT.
IF THE LAW PASSES AND THERE'S A
METHOD IN A PROCESS TO GO
THROUGH THAT A PUBLIC BIG COULD
BE FUNDED WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS.
THE BEST CASE SCENARIO FOR A
SOLVENT PUBLIC BANK IS TEN YEARS
OF THE OLD MAXIM MATURITY ON A
COUNTY INVESTMENT IS.
FIVE SO WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT AS THIS LEGISLATION
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD IT IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT NO PUBLIC
DOLLARS FROM THE COUNTY POOL
WILL EVER GO INTO ONE OF THESE
BANKS TO FIND IT.
AT THE BEGINNING AND FOR THE
MORE THE COMPLIANCE AND OVERHEAD
COSTS OF MEETING THE CURRENT
THINKING RULES ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE.
AND SO THE THE COST OF DOING
THAT COMPLAINTS.
CASH FLOW IN THE BANK FOR
CERTAIN NUMBER OF YEARS IT'S
IT'S JUST NOT FEASIBLE IN OUR
PRISON THAT THE STUDY WILL SHOW
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
INDIVIDUALLY UNDER THE BILL.
I'M I'M NOT CLEAR IF THE STUDY --
IF IT DOES SO THAT IT'S REALLY
IN FEASIBLE DECIDE TO TAKE IT TO
THE VOTERS.
TO CONFIRM IT'S NOT FEASIBLE OR
THE STUDY SAYS IT'S NOT FEASIBLE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PUT IT TO THE
VOTERS.
BUT THAT PROPONENTS ARE YOU KNOW
VERY -- PASSIONATE AND SO
PRESENT THE DOLLAR TO PASS THIS
COULD BE A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ASKED TO FIND A
LOCAL STUDY.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS IF THE STUDY
SHOWS THAT IT'S NOT.
NOT FEASIBLE SO THOSE ARE
CONCERNS WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
IT'S ABUNDANTLY CLEAR FROM THE
GET GO THAT.
THERE'S NO COUNTY MONEY FOR THIS
HELLO.
BUT THAT THE RESPECT ASPIRIN
ABOUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS THING
WHAT HAPPENED A COUPLE COMMENTS
AND ONE OF THE ITEMS JUST
BROUGHT UP WHERE WAS GOING FOR
THE HEARING COMMITTEE COULD
DECEIVE POLICE FORCE ARE SIR
FIRST CLASS ORGANIZATION WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE JASON L<c.cyan>G WITH</c>
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WERE ON
THE FOURTH POLICY CAN MANY NOW
AND WE STILL HAVE YET TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN WHEN A PUBLIC BANK TAKES
ON LOSSES -- AND HAS NOT BEEN
ANSWERED I THINK APPROPRIATELY
CERTAINLY NOT IF YOU PUT ON A A
BANKING LANDS IN AND ASK THE
QUESTION.
THE ANSWER SEEMED TO BE
INADEQUATE WE'VE HEARD THAT --
THE BILL REQUIRES FDIC INSURANCE --
WE'VE HEARD THAT THE BILL
REQUIRES A FEASIBILITY STUDY BUT
IN REALITY.
EVERY BANK TAKES ALL LOSSES --
NO MATTER WHAT THE FEASIBILITY
STUDY SAYS.
PUBLIC BANK WILL TAKE ON LOSSES
THE MOST RISK ADVERSE BANK
OPERATING IN THE MOST SAFE AND
SOUND MANNER WILL HAVE LOSSES.
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR JOBS -- THEY
GET ILL -- AND SO THE QUESTION
HAS NOT BEEN ANSWERED.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
PUBLIC BANK TAKES TAKES ALL
LOSSES FROM FROM LOANS THAT IT
MAKES.
YOU KNOW IN A IN A IN A PRIVATE
BANK -- THE SHAREHOLDERS ARE
ULTIMATELY ARE THE ONES THAT PUT
UP THE CAPITAL -- THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY THE OWNER'S EQUITY --
SO YOU HAVE SORT OF FDIC
INSURANCE WHICH IS A GOOD THING
BUT THAT ONLY PROTECT YOUR
DEPOSITORS HE DOESN'T PROTECT
YOUR OWNER'S EQUITY AND IN THE
CASE OF THE PUBLIC BANK THE
OWNER'S EQUITY IS THE TAXPAYER.
THE TXPAYERS PUTTING UP THE
CAPITAL TO STAND UP THE BANK AND
WHEN YOU HAVE AN EROSION OF THAT
CAPITAL DUE TO THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE LOAN LOSSES.
WE STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IN THIS INSTANCE
WITH THE STATE HAVE TO COME IN
AND STEP IN AND BACK FILL THOSE
LOSSES WITH A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HAVE TO TAKE IT OUT OF ITS OWN
BUDGET. TO BACK FILL THOSE
LOSSES AND IF IT DOES WHAT
HAPPENS OTHER PRIORITIES LIKE
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
WE APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS.
RECOGNITION THAT THERE IS A
DISPARATE TAX TREATMENT -- FOR A
PUBLIC BANK FIRST AS A PRIVATE
BANK.
AND THE ANALYSIS EVEN CONCLUDES
THAT THAT PUTS PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS AT A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE TO A PUBLIC BANK.
THAT'S GOING TO MOST ACUTELY BE
FELT BY YOUR COMMUNITY BANKS
YOUR YOUR STATE CHARTERED
INSTITUTIONS THAT OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA AND LESS IMPACTFUL
PROBABLY TO THE LARGER BANKS --
AND THEY FINALLY LET ME JUST SAY
THAT IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT --
WE'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT -- THE
LAST FOUR POLICY COMMITTEES THAT --
THIS IS A A PUBLIC BANK FOR THE
PUBLIC GOOD.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WERE NOT
ALLOWING THE PUBLIC IN CHARTER
CITIES TO HAVE A SAY.
IN WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT A
BANK A PUBLIC BANK.
IN THAT WERE ONLY LIMITING THE
PUBLIC VOTE -- SPECIFICALLY TO
GENERAL LAS CITIES THAT'S THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE THE GENERAL US
CITIES OR OR CHARTER CITIES HAVE
THE PUBLIC HAS LESS OF A RIGHT
THE TAXPAYERS HAVE LESS OF A SAY
IN A IN A CHARTER CITY.
THAN A GENERAL LAW CITY.
YOU KNOW THE POLLING SHOWS THAT
60% OF INDIVIDUALS LIKELY VOTERS
DO NOT WANT TO PUBLIC BANK IN
LOS ANGELES THE CHARTER BE
AMENDMENT IN NOVEMBER FAILED BY
58% OF THE VOTE.
THE PUBLIC DOESN'T WANT A PUBLIC
BANK WE URGE A NO VOTE.
HE'S MY SERVER NOT GONNA WELCOME
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION PERSON
LAST NAME ORGANIZATION.
ROBBER WILSON WITH A CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE IN
OPPOSITION THIS WAS.
THE MORNING CORNELIUS BURKE WITH
THE BEAR COUNCIL PULSE OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING ELLERY NEAR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
IT'S LIKE TO BE TO DO A LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION LOOKING FOR
ALASKA.
WE BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP OUR WITNESSES
WHO WERE OPPOSITION AND HAVE OUR
TO AUTHORS HERE TO BILL TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ANSWER JUST ONE ITEM THAT IN
YOUR URN IT OVER? TO US IN
NUMBER CHIU IN SANTIAGO TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER ANY ITEMS -- THAT
THEY HAVE HEARD.
BUT IN REGARDS TO THE APPROVAL
PROCESS OF A BANG.
FIRST AND FOREMOST -- HAVE TO
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION ORGANIZED
AND I'M GONNA PARAPHRASING IF
YOU'RE FOLLOWING ALONG HOMES ON
AGE SIXTEEN THE BILL.
ON THE MAIN THING IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT STUDY WOULD NEED TO BE
ADVANCED.
ON THEN UP FOR PRIOR TO THE
PUBLIC VOTE.
BRING THE VOTERS IN TO EXPRESS
THEIR VOICE.
THE GOVERNING BOARD WHO ISSUED
THE STUDY ON GIVING EXAMPLE.
ABOARD SUPERVISORS ARE CITY
COUNCIL.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADOPT THE
STUDY.
REGARDLESS I AM ONLY THEN.
BUT WITH A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE
ADVANCED.
SO I THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE
READING.
THE THE BILL BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE
MAY NEED TO STILL BE SOME
QUESTIONS ON THAT.
IN CLARIFICATION.
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO SOME OF
CHIU.
C. OR SANTIAGO SEETHER ANY ITEMS
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO COVER PRIOR TO GOING TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS -- THAT
YOU HEARD FROM OPPOSITION SURE
THERE ARE A COUPLE ITEMS ARE
PART OF THE OPPOSITION AND
ANTICIPATE -- SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT SO HAPPY DID TO DRILL
DOWN WITH REGARDS TO TO TAX
TREATMENT IT IS NOT TYPICAL THAT
WE WOULD TAX.
OF PUBLIC ENTITIES -- AND AND
CLEARLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- A
LOCAL JURISDICTION.
THAT DECIDES TO USE PUBLIC FUNDS
TO HELP CAPITALIZE THE BANK.
IT WOULD BE UNORTHODOX TO
SUGGEST THAT WE OUGHT TO TAX OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS -- AND I WOULD
SAY WE WOULD BE TREATING THE
PUBLIC BANKS I WAS WE WOULD
CREDIT UNIONS WHICH ALSO ARE NOT
SUBJECTED TO TAXES SO -- THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A POLICY CALL -- BUT
ONE THAT WE THINK MAKES SENSE
WITH REGARDS TO THE ANTICIPATION
OF LOSSES AS THE CHAIRMAN JUST
SAID.
THE PROCESS TO APPLY FOR CHARTER
WOULD INVOLVE THE ANALYSIS IN
THE FEASIBILITY STUDY -- THE
PUTTING TOGETHER A BUSINESS PLAN
AND THOSE TWO ITEMS WOULD BE
REQUIRED BEFORE SAY LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL WOULD WOULD APPROVE IT.
CLEARLY THE QUESTION THAT WAS
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITH LOSSES THOSE WOULD
BE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS.
THAT WE WOULD EXPECT TO BE
ADDRESSED IN A BUSINESS PLAN IN
A FEASIBILITY STUDY.
AND CERTAINLY QUESTIONS THAT A
PUBLIC WOULD WANT TO KNOW --
BEFORE SAY A CITY COUNCIL WERE
TO VOTE ON IT -- FOR AS A VOTERS
WOULD CONSIDER IT AT THE BALLOT
BOX SO I WOULD -- THESE WOULD BE
ADDRESSED -- THROUGH THAT
PROCESS -- I THINK THOSE WERE
PROBABLY THE TWO MAIN ISSUES
THAT I HEARD.
REYES BY THE OPPOSITION BUT
OBVIOUSLY HAPPY TO ANSWER ALL
THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IN A WE LIKE
TO BE A TOURIST CENTER GOING ON
AS YOU'D LIKE ME TO JOIN IN ON
THE ALL RESPECT COMMITTEE IN THE
END LEAVE IT TO THE TO ONE OF
THE AUTHORS A PERCENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATORS WOULD
LIKE TO BE BUILT OPEN UP FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE THIS TIME SO BY SHEER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO.
WHEN I BECAME THE TREASURER FOR
THE COUNTY OF ORANGE?
I HAD A PROBLEM WITH MY BANK
[inaudible]
THEY THEY DID NOT APPRECIATE
HAVING FIFTY THOUSAND WELFARE
RECIPIENTS SHOW UP ON THE FIRST
OF THE MONTH THEIR BRANCHES.
IT LIKE THE BABY DIAPERS AND ALL
THE REST AND AND THEY THEY GAVE
ME A LOT OF PUSH BACK ON I I
SORT OF NEW TO THE JOB.
AND I GATHER THIS IS CRAZY THAT
THESE BANKS AREN'T HELPING ME
OUT SO I I CONTACTED OF A FRIEND
OF MINE GARY FINDLEY WHO IS THE
TOP BANKING ATTORNEY IN ORANGE
COUNTY -- HIS WIFE IS BECKY
BAILEY FAMILY WHO IS INVOLVED
WITH THIS.
THE ASSOCIATION AND THE STATE.
AND I RETAIN HIM AND I SAID YOU
KNOW I'VE I'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO ISSUE WELFARE CHECKS I'M
GETTING PUSHED BACK.
AND SO WE CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
OF STARTING A BANK AND AT THE
TIME THE ONLY BANK WE FOUND THAT
WAS DONE BY A BY A GOVERNMENTAL
TYPE.
ORGANIZATION WITH A RESERVATION
SOMEWHERE IN THAT.
MID MID PART OF OF THE OF THE
COUNTRY -- BUT I YOU KNOW SO SO
NORTH DAKOTA CAME AFTER MY
RESEARCH -- SO WE STARTED DOWN
THIS JOURNEY OF STARTING A BANK
JUST FOR YOU KNOW TO HELP THOSE
THAT ARE GETTING.
CHECKS.
FOR WELFARE NOT TO START A BANK
BANK BUT SOMEHOW MAYBE A POINT
OF SALE CARDS AND AND THEN
REFILL THOSE AND JUST TRY TO
HELP.
A CERTAIN POPULATION SO WE MET.
AND WE CONTACTED THE FEDERAL
RESERVE THEY GAVE ME A LETTER OF
APPROVAL I WE CONTACTED THE FBI
SEE GOT A LETTER OF APPROVAL.
CONTACTED -- THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF BANKING CAME ALL
THE WAY DOWNTOWN LA HAD A PHONE
CONVERSATION I'VE LAID OUT THE
BUSINESS APPROACH.
AND THEN THEY THEY ASKED HOW I
FELT THAT THE MEETING WENT
BECAUSE THEY WERE SUGGESTING
OTHER BENEFITS.
AND I SAID I THOUGHT YOU WERE
SUPPOSED TO THROW ME OUT OF THIS
OFFICE WITHIN THE FIRST TWO
MINUTES -- FOR PROPOSING AN IDEA
LIKE THIS AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME AND HOW
IT HOW IT ALL PLAYED OUT.
THEY WANTED A BUSINESS PLAN WE
BUILT A BUSINESS PLAN.
WEEK WEEKS WHICH SUCKS.
SENATE AROUND ALL THE BANKS IN
THE COUNTY THAT WERE SMALLER NOT
THE BIG BANKS.
JUST TO GET THEIR INPUT.
AND AND WHAT CAME BACK WAS STATE
ALL THE CEOS OF THESE BANKS ARE
ONLY LIKE THE IDEA BUT THEY
WANTED TO SERVE ON THE BOARD.
BUT WE GET ALL THIS ANALYSIS WE
LOOK AT ALL THE COSTS.
IN AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
COST BENEFIT WAS TO MINIMAL IT
WAS JUST IT WAS IT WAS SOMETHING
BUT IT WASN'T.
ENOUGH TO SAY OKAY HOW DO WE
TAKE ON ALL THE RISK ALL THE
ACTIVITY.
ALL THE AUDITS.
ALL THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
AND IF WE HAVE ONE LITTLE BLIP
THEN WE HAVE A LOSS AND HOW DO
WE JUSTIFY THAT.
SO WAS IN A FUN EXPERIENCE SO
IT'S KIND OF FUN THAT ALL THESE
MEMORIES.
COME BACK -- SO MEMBERS TO IN
SANTIAGO YOU KNOW DOING THIS
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO BEFORE YOU
WERE BORN.
AND A AND M..
AND NOW LOOKING AT AT THIS AS A
BILL.
SAW.
I'M COMING FROM MY OWN PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING GONE
THROUGH AN INCREDIBLE JOURNEY --
EVEN SURPRISING MY LEGAL COUNSEL
WHO RIDE WE WOULDN'T GET AS FAR
AS WE EVEN DID JUST.
THAT.
THERE WAS AT LEAST SOME
RECEPTIVE ATTY THE IDEA BUT WHAT
AND THEN IT CAME BACK TO HOW DO
I DEAL WITH MY C. E. O. AT THE
COUNTY.
AND AND AND AND AT THAT TIME I
WAS HAVING.
TO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS THAT WERE
UPSET WHEN THEY WERE THIRTY
HEARING.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO BUT IT
WAS LIKE OKAY THIS IS NOT A CORE
THIS IS NOT A CORE FUNCTION OF
GOVERNMENT YOU KNOW?
AND SO.
BECAUSE THE COST FOR THE SAVINGS
WERE AT THE END OF THE DAY NOT.
THEY WERE JUST TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THE END OF
THE DAY DOING ALL THAT.
AND I SAID I THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO START A BANK SO I I I
COMING FROM THAT BACKGROUND I
LOOKED AT I LOOKED AT ALL THE
BENEFITS THAT YOU KNOW WE HEAR
THE REASONS WHY WE SHOULD DO
THIS.
I KEEP TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN THE
COMMUNITIES FROM WHICH THEY ARE
SOURCED.
THAT'S DOUBTFUL -- BECAUSE ALL
THE MONEY.
IT'S ACTUALLY A INVESTED IN --
CASH EQUIVALENTS YOU GOT TO KEEP
YOUR MONEY.
EARNING MONEY WHICH MEANS THAT --
YOU KNOW YOU DIVEST FROM
INDUSTRIES AND SECTORS THE
INDIAN CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT VALUES BUT YOU MIGHT-BE THERE JUST WITH WHERE THE
MONEY IS BEING INVESTED.
LOWER ADMINISTRATIVE FEES PAID
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AT TO LARGE
BANKS I THINK THE SAVINGS ARE
MINIMAL INCREASE THE LENDING
CAPACITY OF LOCAL.
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS VIA
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE PUBLIC
BANK BUT THEN YOU HAVE EXPOSURE
TO LOAN LOSSES WHICH IS A WHOLE
NOTHER DISCUSSION.
STRENGTHENED SMALL BUSINESS
LENDING COMMUNITIES BY OFFERING
LOANS PERHAPS IT WILL MARKET
RATES ND I I ALSO SAY THAT'S A
MAYBE.
AND ADDRESS LOCAL LOCALITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING NEEDS AND
I SAID THAT THAT THAT'S THAT'S
PROBABLY A POSITIVE I WOULDN'T
SEE IT AS A AS A MAJOR POSITIVE.
SO I JUST PUT THAT ALL OTHER
MISTER CHAIR JUST THIS CONTEXT
OF THE HISTORY THAT I'VE ENJOYED
AND AND SO WITH THAT I I WILL
I'LL BE OPPOSED BECAUSE I JUST.
I I I I GET WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO BUT I JUST DON'T SEE IT AS
BEING A IN SOMETHING THAT.
IS BENEFICIAL AT THE END OF THE
DAY TO TAXPAYERS TO TO TO
COMPETE IN THE BROAD SCHEME OF
THINGS.
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR SO I
DON'T I'M NOT ASKING QUESTIONS I
JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
HISTORY OF ALL THE FUN.
OF THAT THIS IS AND I'M SURE
THAT TESSA MEMBERS CHIU AND
SANTIAGO HAD A LOT OF FUN
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER BECAUSE
IT'S A BIG PROJECT SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION THE FLOOR BY
CENTER WIENER -- WILL HAVE
DECEMBER CHEWED TO BE ABLE TO
COMMENT ON THE YEAR.
LIFTED RESPONDED TO SOME OF THAT
AND AND LOVE HEARING ABOUT THAT
THAT YOUR EXERIENCE AND AND
HAPPY TO CHAT WITH YOU ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE MORE LET ME SEE
REALLY. THREE THINGS FIRST WE DO
KNOW THAT THE PROCESS. FOR ANY
LOCAL JURISDICTION TO MOVE FOR
WITH THE CHART OF A PUBLIC BANK
IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY NO BONES
ABOUT IT I HAVE SAID THAT.
THE I THINK THE RISK WITH THIS
LEGISLATION AS WE HAVE PLACE SO
MANY REQUIREMENTS.
ON WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO CHARTER
PUBLIC BANK THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
THE END OF FIVE OR TEN YEARS
FROM NOW.
NO LOCAL JURISDICTION MAY BE
SUCCESSFUL AT THAT BECAUSE IT'S
HARD.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
REASON WHY WE SHOULDN'T TRY AND
AND AND AND WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE
PUBLIC BANKS AT THIS TIME IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO THE EXAMPLE OF
THE SUCCESS OF THE PUBLIC BANK
EXPERIENCE IN IN NORTH DAKOTA.
THESE ARE THE SAME QUESTIONS
THAT WERE SUGGESTED BEFORE WHEN
WE JUST HAD A PRIVATE HEALTH
SYSTEM THAT DIDN'T WORK ABOUT
SUGGESTING WE NEED TO MOVE FOR
WITH THE OR BEFORE WE HAD A
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
BEFORE PUBLIC TRANSIT WAS A
CONCEPT OVER FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION WAS A CONCEPT.
YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE
IN TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO LET ME
JUST SAY A FEW THINGS WHAT IS
HAPPENED WITHIN THE BANKING
INDUSTRY IN SPECIFICALLY.
WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH WALL STREET
BANKS AND THEIR IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST DECADE SO
THAT WAS TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO.
IN THE PAST DECADE WE'VE HAD
MILLIONS OF CONSUMERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED PREDATORY LENDING.
WE'VE HAD MILLIONS OF FAKE BANK
ACCOUNTS OPEN IN THEIR NAMES
WE'VE HAD MILLIONS OF CONSUMERS
WHO'VE LOST. FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN INTEREST
PAYMENTS AFTER THE GREAT
RECESSION.
WE'VE HAD.
AN UNTOLD NUMBER OF HOMEOWNERS
WHO'VE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY THE
MORTGAGE FORECLOSURE CRISIS
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY
GREEDY LENDERS.
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
DENIED ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
AND THE PUBLIC WHOSE MONIES ARE
CURRENTLY BEING INVESTED AGAINST
THEIR VALUES AND FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRIES WITH GUN
MANUFACTURERS WITH PRIVATE
PRISONS.
WITH COMPANIES WITH UNFAIR LABOR
PRACTICES WITHIN THE PAST DECADE
SOMETHING IS TRULY BROKEN.
WITH THE PRIVATE BANKING SYSTEM.
AND I ALSO STE I JUST MENTION
THAT -- OVER THE PAST TWENTY
YEARS THE LARGEST WALL STREET
BANKS HAVE.
PUSHED OUT 75% OF CALIFORNIA
LOCAL BANKS.
SO SOMETHING'S FUNDAMENTALLY
BROKEN SINCE YOUR EXPERIENCE
FROM TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO AND
WHAT WE ARE SAYING S AT THIS
TIME.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE WANT
TO EXPLORE IF THERE'S A
DIFFERENT WAY IT WILL BE
DIFFICULT IT WILL BE HARD.
BUT WE THINK THESE ARE QUESTIONS
THAT WE NEED TO ASK AND WE HOPE
BY ASKING THESE QUESTIONS EITHER.
THERE ARE SUCCESSES AND
ESTABLISHING.
LOCAL PUBLIC BANKS FOR THE WALL
STREET BANKS.
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES TO BE
MORE RESPONSIVE TO WHAT.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NEED EITHER OUTCOME
WOULD WORK WELL FOR US.
BUT I THINK NOT HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IS REALLY TO THE
DETRIMENT OF ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AND WE HAVE THE S. IN HERTZBERG
CONSIDER BELL WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
SPEAK QUICKLY AND THIS RIGHT
HERE THANK YOU MISTER AND I
TOTALLY APPRECIATE.
THE ARGUMENT OF HAVING A LITTLE
LEVERAGE.
WITH THE BANKS BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THE FIRM OF L<c.cyan>G</c>
AND LANE WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
AS WELL TO WHAT WAS JUST SAID.
I DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD TO IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEASURE
WILL TURN IT OVER TO CENTER
HERTZBERG IN CENTER ABOUT.
THE ONLY PUBLIC BANK.
NAY STATES WAS FORMED ONE
HUNDRED YEARS AGO IN NORTH
DAKOTA.
IN A AT THE TIME.
WHERE NORTH DAKOTA IS
[inaudible]
ECONOMIC FOUNDATION WAS INFORMED
BY AGRICULTURE.
AND THERE WERE BASICALLY.
KNOWN FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
AND THE BANK IN NORTH DAKOTA.
ONLY ACCEPTS DEPOSITS FROM THE
STATE AND THERE AGENCIES AND NOT
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
JUST THE STATE [inaudible]
FARM.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
TREASURER YEAR TWO YEARS AGO
CAMBER TOOK A LOOK AT THIS
NOTION OF STATE BANKS.
AND WE'VE HAD A SERIES OF
STUDIES.
DONE. FOR MANY YEARS
[inaudible]
BOOKS WRITTEN. FOR MANY YEARS.
I'M CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
[inaudible]
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS EXTRAORDINARY IS WORLD CLASS.
THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF STATE EMPLOYEE MONEY.
IS INVESTED THROUGH A VERY
POLITICALLY -- SENSITIVE
ORGANIZATION CALLOUSED
ORGANIZATIONS CASTERS AND
CALPERS.
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SINCE SO
MANY TIMES A REMEMBER WITH --
MAXINE WATERS ARE APARTHEID.
ISSUES OF INVESTMENT IN OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WE HAVE IMPOSED
UPON RESOURCES OF CALIFORNIA
EXTRAORDINARY VALUES NO QUESTION.
WE ALSO HAVE DOZENS OF
INSTRUMENTS FROM THRIFTS TO ALL
KINDS OF INSTRUMENTS. TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL TOOLS SOME OF THEM ARE
QUESTIONABLE PAYDAY LENDING AND
STOP WHICH WORKS EXAMINING NOW.
IN THE LARGER DYNAMIC.
AND I WOULD FURTHER SUGGEST THE
STATE TREASURER AND LOCAL
TREASURES PARTICULARLY OF LARGER
JURISDICTIONS.
ARE PROFESSIONALLY ADVISED AND
SQUEEZE THE HECK.
OUT OF PRIVATE SECTOR BANKS. TO
TO GET THE BEST POSSIBLE RATES
ON DEALS.
WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE BANK
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
THAT ARE RUN BY GOVERNMENT AND
THE COST AND TIME AND IS
CHALLENGING.
SO I'M VERY SKEPTICAL AND
DOUBTFUL AS TO WHETHER OR NOT A
PUBLIC BANK STRUCTURE WORKS.
IN A PLACE LIKE CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN WHERE WE ARE AND I'VE
CERTAINLY GRAPPLED WITH THE
CANNABIS SPACE.
THE THE NORTH DAKOTA JUST YOU
KNOW ASSURE YOU KNOW BUT FOR THE
RECORD HERE.
THERE IS NO FDIC INSURANCE
DEPARTMENTS NO FEDERAL DEPOSIT
INSURANCE.
IT'S THE GENERAL FUND OF THE
STATE THAT GUARANTEES THE
DEPOSITS OF CREDITORS OF
DEPOSITORS.
DIFFICULTLY RISKY TO THE GENERAL
FUND.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THEY DON'T
INTEGRATE THROUGH THE FIFTY I
SEE PROGRAM FOR THE BETWEEN
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
INSURANCE.
THAT BEING SAID.
I'M OF FOR THIS TODAY BECAUSE I
LIKE THE AUTHORS.
AND I THINK THAT AND I THINK
YOU'RE SMART GUYS.
AND I THINK YOUR HONORABLE
INSINCERE.
I THINK YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS.
THE SUCH A PRETTY HIGH MARKS IN
TERMS OF THE BILL WITH THE
STANDARDS ARE.
AND I THINK BE ABLE.
TO MAKE THAT IS CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
BUT I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT AND
RIGHTEOUS THING TO DO TO ALWAYS
BE DILIGENT TO ALWAYS INVENT THE
FUTURE TO ALWAYS KEEP PUSHING TO
ALWAYS FIGURE OUT IF THERE'S NEW
AND BETTER WAYS TO MAKE IT WORK.
TO LEVERAGE PEOPLE IF YOU CAN.
YEAH HI MARK BUT I THINK YOU'LL
FIGURE IT OUT AND I THINK YOU'LL
TELL THE TRUTH JUST WHAT THE
OUTCOMES GOING TO BE BECAUSE THE
END OF THE DAY MONEY TELLS THE
TRUTH ON THESE THINGS WITH THE
PEOPLE GROW INVEST WHAT'S RATE
OF RETURN WITH THE COSTS ARTS.
IT'S ARITHMETIC IS BROOKLYN USED
TO SAY.
NO CREATE COMPLEXITY TO IT.
BUT I AM PERSUADED BY YOUR
ARGUMENT THAT LET'S GIVE IT A
SHOT.
YOU KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO IN GOVERNMENT
THAT IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH IS THAT
WE DON'T ENGAGE IN THE CUTTING
EDGE THINKING.
CONTINUALLY PUSH THE ENVELOPE.
ALL THE ARGUMENTS I GAVE TO YOU
ARE BACKWARD ARGUMENTS THEY
HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
CAN YOU INVENT THE FUTURE I
DON'T KNOW I THINK IT'S TOUGH.
GO FIGURE IT OUT.
I AM MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTERS PRISONER BELL --
JUST -- OF QUESTION OF THE
PURPOSE OF A PUBLIC BANK.
I KNOW SOONER STAFF REPORT
THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PUBLIC BANKS [inaudible]
AND I'M KIND OF TYPICALLY
INTEREST -- AND HOW A PUBLIC
BANK WILL HAVE -- PEOPLE IN
POVERTY [inaudible]
AND WHEN I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR OF I WAS SO ON THE
FINANCE COMMITTEE OF THE COUNTY.
AND WE GOT A NOTICE.
FROM THE BANK SAYING THAT THEY
WANTED TO CHARGE [inaudible]
A FEE. FOR OUR CAL WORKS CARD
ISN'T THAT THE SAME THING THAT
HAPPENED AND ORANGE COUNTY
PROBABLY.
OF WE ALSO -- THEY SAID THEY
WANTED TO CHARGE A FEE. TO EACH
TRANSACTION.
USED BY SOMEBODY WITH A
ELECTRONIC DEPOSIT THAT WENT
INTO THEIR ACCOUNT. FOR CAL
WORKS WE ALSO HAD -- OF YOUR THE
PUBLIC CHARGE -- SOMEBODY UNDER
PUBLIC CHARGE JOURNAL ASSISTANCE
WE CALL IT.
THEY'RE GIVEN LIKE THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
OUT OF THE COUNTY AND THEY ALSO
CHARGED -- PEOPLE ON GENERAL
ASSISTANCE -- A FEE.
ARE THE COUNTY.
AT THE BANK.
IN A CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP.
WHERE THERE ARE PROVIDING
SERVICE?
OF FOR THE COUNTY AND THEIR
GENERAL DEPOSITS AND SERVICES.
AT THE COUNTY NEED WHICH
INCLUDED.
THE WEALTH OF THE WORLD CAL
WORKS WITH YOU KNOW THAT'S I
THINK WE REFERRED TO WELFARE BUT
HOW IT WORKS -- DEPOSITS.
AND THEN I ALSO FOUND OUT
[inaudible]
RECENTLY.
THERE ARE JOB PEOPLE ON SS I
HIGH.
PER ATM TRANSACTIONS ARE CHARGED.
EIGHT DOLLARS IN SOME CASES --
THERE [inaudible]
TRANSACTIONS [inaudible]
ARM. EIGHT DOLLARS IS A LOT OF
MONEY IN THESE CHARGES ARE A LOT
OF MONEY [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
PEOPLE IN POVERTY.
ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AND I A
KIND OF WHAT I WANT TO KNOW IS.
FROM MY STANDPOINT.
THE PURPOSE OF THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT CITY GOVERNMENT IS.
TO MAYBE ELIMINATE.
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN
SOCIETY HOMELESSNESS POVERTY AND
SO FORTH.
BUT WHEN WE ARE TAKING OUR MONEY
AND PUTTING IT INTO.
A INSTITUTION THAT IS THEN.
CHARGING FOR THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
MONEY.
AT THE SAME TIME LOANING OUR
TO YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT
[inaudible] ONE OF INVESTOR IT
COULD NOT IT MIGHT BE IN SOME
OTHER STATE PROBABLY.
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO MY QUESTION IS.
WE HAVE 20% PART IN CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD WE HAVE SOME.
CONSCIOUS ABOUT.
THE DEPOSITS IN OPERATIONS AND
AND I WANT TO KNOW HOW THE
PUBLIC THANK [inaudible]
CONCEPT.
CAN BE USED TO ENCOURAGE THAT.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IT COULD BE USED TO ENCOURAGE
THAT.
DO NOT CHARGE THESE PEOPLE THESE
FEES.
BECAUSE I'M GETTING A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS AND I'M REAL SERIOUS
BECAUSE I HEARD THIS.
TRUST THIS WEEKEND.
AN EARLIER FRIDAY.
WHEN I HAD MY SENIOR HEALTH FAIR
IN SAN JOSE AND I HEARD PEOPLE
COMING UP TO ME?
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW.
THEY WERE.
LOSING THEIR HOUSES BECAUSE A
CAR FOR THE RANT.
IN THEIR IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THEY'RE LOSING THEIR PLACES TO
LIVE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME THEY'RE
CHARGING A SET BY SO WHAT'S
WRONG WITH WHAT WHAT'S.
THEY SAID WELL WE GOT THIS
LETTER SAYING WE WE HAVE.
TO PAY THIS EXTRA BE
[inaudible]
SO.
I'D LIKE TO AUTHORS OF THE BILL
PERHAPS [inaudible]
TO HOW CAN.
PUBLIC BANKS BE USED TO HELP.
OUR PEOPLE IN NEED THAT OUR
GOVERNMENTS -- ESPECIALLY --
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS TO BE IN A
COUNTY.
COUNTY COUNTY -- ORDER
SUPERVISORS MEMBER FOR TWELVE
YEARS.
YOU KNOW OUR BASIC PURPOSE IS TO
HELP THESE PEOPLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I I
THINK YOUR QUESTION FRAMES
EXACTLY WHY THERE IS SO MUCH
SUPPORT FOR MOVING THIS FORWARD
AND I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT OUR LOWEST INCOME.
CALIFORNIANS BUT IT'S ABOUT MOST
INCOMES ARE OUTSIDE OF THE TOP
1% WHO DO NOT FEEL LIKE THE
CURRENT.
BANKING SYSTEM THAT'S BEING
DRIVEN BY WALL STREET BANKS ARE
SERVING THEIR NEEDS.
AS I ALLUDED TO BEFORE -- THE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL COMES FROM
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
DON'T THINK THAT THE PREDATORY
LENDING PRACTICES THAT THEY'VE
SEEN FROM WALL STREET OUR
ADDRESSING THEIR NEEDS CERTAINLY
THE NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS.
WHEN IT COMES TO HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING THE FACT THAT THERE
IS SO LITTLE?
ACCESS TO CAPITAL FROM WALL
STREET BANKS TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO DRESSER HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS AND AGAIN THE LOWEST
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
IS IS IS A MAJOR REASON WHY
REMOVING FOR WITH THIS I WILL
MENTION.
BEFORE THE THE ARE ARE -- RECENT
DEPARTED MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LEE BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY
HE HAD.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
HE WANTED ME TO CARRY A BILL. TO
PUSH WALL STREET ANKS TO DO A
BETTER JOB.
AND AND I KNOW ACTION FOUR OF US --
IS A LOBBYIST FOR THE CITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO AND SHE%
KNEW.
THAT MERELY HAD WANTED US TO
MOVE FOR THE BILL -- TO PUSH
WALL STREET BANKS TO PROVIDE LOW
OR NO INTEREST LOANS TO CITIES
TO ADDRESS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CRISIS DATA SOMETHING PUBLIC
BANKS COULD DO.
I SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE.
THE CHALLENGE IN RECENT YEARS IN.
IN BEING ABLE TO EMPLOY OUR
LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO CAPITAL TO EXPAND THEIR
BUSINESSES FROM THIS SECTOR.
AND STUDENTS WHO ARE LOOKING TO
MOVE UP THE EDUCATIONAL LADDER
SO THEY CAN GET THE JOBS THAT
THEY NEED TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
THEY HAVE BEN NOT MET BY WHAT
ARE WALL STREET BANKS ARE DOING
SO -- WE FOR STRUCTURE THIS BILL
TO REQUIRE.
A PROPOSAL FOR PUBLIC BANK TO
DELINEATE WHAT WHO THEY'RE
TRYING TO SERVE AS A MOVE FOR
WHETHER IT BE.
THE HOUSING SECTOR WHETHER BE
PREDATORY LENDERS WHETHER BE
SMALL BUSINESSES SO THIS WOULD
BE LAID OUT IN THE BUSINESS PLAN.
PROPOSED TO CITY COUNCILS
PROPOSED TO VOTERS FOR THEIR
SUPPORT BUT IT IS EXACTLY THE
REASON WHY WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THIS NOW BUT LET ME.
AND WITH ONE FINAL THANKS WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO DO IS TRY TO WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO REPLICATE TYPICAL
RETAIL SERVICES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING PROVIDED.
EITHER BY PRIVATE BANKS FOR BY
CREDIT UNIONS OR COMMUNITY BANKS
THAT IS NOT THE PURPOSE OF
TRYING TO MOVE FORWARD.
BUT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ENSURE THAT WHAT THE BANKING
INDUSTRY SAYS THAT THERE DO
WHICH IS PROVIDE CAPITAL.
LENDS.
PROVIDE LENDING AND LOANS TO TO
PEOPLE TO ACHIEVE.
THEIR GOALS AND OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY WHATHAPPENS AS OPPOSED TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW WHICH IS PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE BEING PUT TO USE.
WITH INDUSTRIES THAT DO NOT
SERVE CALIFORNIANS INDUSTRIES
WHOSE VALUES ARE ANTITHETICAL TO
CALIFORNIANS.
AND INDUSTRIES THAT CERTAINLY
ARE NOT HELPING THE LOWEST
INCOME.
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE.
THAT I'VE TALKED.
TO THAT ARE ON SSI.
THAT ARE DEVELOP ME DISABLED.
THE BILL ME DISABLED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA TO OUR DEPARTMENT OR
LETTERMAN ACT.
THEY'RE BEING CHARGED.
THE EIGHT DOLLARS FOR THEIR
SERVICING.
ON THEIR ACCOUNTS.
THERE IS A A PUBLIC.
CHARGE THEIR THEIR THE PUBLIC
WE'RE WE'RE WE THE PUBLIC.
OUR BY.
THE LATERAN ACT RESPONSIBLE FOR
THESE PEOPLE.
IN TERMS OF THEIR LIVES IN THEIR
STABILITY AND LIVING CONDITIONS
[inaudible] FOR EVERY
TRANSACTION THEY NEED TO HAVE
[inaudible]
OF AND I JUST DON'T I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE CAN'T.
LOOK AT SOME OPTIONS LIKE A
PUBLIC BANKER ANY OTHER OPTION
OR I DON'T KNOW WHAT TYPE OF
PUBLIC BANK.
THAT WE CAN USE TO PROTECT THESE
PEOPLE BECAUSE THIS IS GOT TO BE
ONE OF OUR PRIMARY GOALS.
IS TO PROTECT THESE PEOPLE FROM.
HAVING LESS INCOME BECAUSE YOU
KNOW QUITE FRANKLY.
EVERY YEAR IN THE BUDGET WE
CONSIDER INCREASES [inaudible]
FOUR COST OF LIVING.
FOR PEOPLE ON THE LATTER ENACT.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT AND ON SSI
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT EVERY YEAR
TO GET FUNDS.
IN THE BUDGET.
AND IT'S ALWAYS A BIG FIGHT.
AND WE HAD ONE YEAR AT ONE POINT
WHERE THE PROGRAMS FOR LETTERMAN
ACT.
IT WAS SIXTEEN YEARS WITHOUT AN
INCREASE SIXTEEN YEARS WENT BY.
WITHOUT AN INCREASE IN FINALLY --
BY SOME PEOPLE.
CHAINING HIMSELF TO THE BARE.
THE FRONT.
OFFICE MARYLAND IN AND I WAS
SITTING HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND THE SERGEANTS CALLED ME.
AND THEY SAID WE SENATOR WE'D
LIKE YOU TO LEAVE.
AND GO TALK TO THESE PEOPLE.
THE MAN AND THEY THEY PULLED ME
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TO TALK TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE.
GOING TO CHAIN THEMSELVES TO THE
BARE.
AND I I THINK I THINK WE GOT TO
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT HERE WE
GOT TO HAVE THIS [inaudible]
RECKONING OF WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
DOING TO PROTECT THESE PEOPLE
BECAUSE THE MONEY IS THE MONEY
IS NOT GOING TO THESE PEOPLE
IT'S GOING.
TO OTHER PLACES AND WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING.
SO I I'M LOOKING I'M LOOKING FOR
ANY KIND OF IMPROVEMENT ON THE
POSSIBILITY OF CREATING A PUBLIC
MAC OR ANY OTHER OPTION.
OR MAYBE SOME OTHER KIND OF
FINANCIAL.
INSTITUTION THAT COULD HELP
[inaudible]
THESE PEOPLE.
SURVIVE IN THIS STATE THAT IS IS
SO HIGH COST OF LIVING FOR THE
IN A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT.
MR TERM MISTER BY JIM I RESPOND.
MEMORY SANTIAGO PLEASE THANK YOU --
I FIRST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING A CO AUTHOR IN AND IT'S
MEANINGFUL THAT TO HAVE YOUR
INPUT -- AND HELP.
THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND LET ME
START OFF BY SAYING THAT IT WHAT
WHAT YOU'VE JUST DESCRIBED IS
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE.
UNACCEPTABLE THAT WHEN SOMEBODY
IS DOWN THAT WAS SOMEBODY IS.
IS IN POVERTY SOMEBODY'S ON SSI
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A BANKING
SYSTEM -- THAT WOULD CHARGE --
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT HIGH
OF A FEE JUST TO ACCESS DOLLARS
WELL I CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHY -- PERHAPS OF THE LOBBYIST
FOR THE BANKING INDUSTRY COULD.
BUT BUT I TELL TELL YOU AMONGST.
ONE OF THE VERY MANY REASONS AS
TO WHY -- I WAS.
MOVED TO ADD COME BARK ON THIS
NEW IDEA.
I'M IN A LOT OF US OF LAID OUT
OF HER REASONS AND WE SEE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES AND WE SEE.
ALMOST POPULATION AND WE SEE
PEOPLE AS A SIGN WE SEE THAT THE
SYSTEM DOES NOT WORKING FOLKS I
MEAN THE BOTTOM LINE IS NOT
WORKING FOR FOLKS WE'RE NOW THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
IN THE WORLD AND WE HAVE THE
LARGEST HOMELESS POPULATION WE
HAVE RENTS ARE SKYROCKETING AND
AND AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT
PUBLIC BANK ISN'T FIX ALL THIS
RIGHT BUT IT'S ONE STEP IT'S ONE
THING BUT WE CAN CHECK A SYSTEM
A WE CAN FIND A DIFFERENT WAY IN
A NEW.
WAY OF DOING THINGS BECAUSE
WE'VE GOT A CHALLENGE THE STATUS
QUO AT THAT HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH PEOPLE.
WHO SOME OF THE MEMBERS HERE AND
WE ALL AGREE WE GOT A CHALLENGE
JUST AS C<c.cyan> IS NOT WORKING FOR</c>
FOLKS THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE?
AND AN END WHEN I BEFORE I WAS
IN PUBLIC OFFICE -- IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
I REMEMBER -- IN WHERE THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND I REPRESENT --
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THE SENIOR
HOUSING PROJECT THAT WAS COMING
UP.
AND I WAS REALLY EXCITED I WENT --
WAS IN AN OFFICE YEAH BUT I
COULDN'T DEAL WITH THAT TRY TO
DUPLICATE THE SORT OF WORK.
AND DURING THE SPEECHES I HAD
HEARD THAT IT TOOK US SEVEN OR
EIGHT YEARS TO PUT THE FINANCING
TOGETHER FOR THIS PROJECT AND I
WAS EXTREMELY DISAPPOINTED
ALTHOUGH I KNEW HOW BENEFICIAL
WAS TO THE COMMUNITY TO HAVE
LESS.
THAN A HUNDRED UNITS COME UP AT
THE THOUGHT OF HAVING TO PUT A
FINANCING MECHANISM FOR THAT
MANY YEARS -- FOR SENIOR HOUSING
JUST DROVE ME NUTS AND I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF BUT WHEN WE WERE
EMBARKING ON THIS -- IT LOOK.
THE WALL STREET BRAND BUT BANK
IS IN RESPONSE TO SHAREHOLDERS
IN IT'S GOING TO TRY THE YIELD
THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT OF PROFIT
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO IT'S THE
PROFIT MOTIVE IT'S HOW THEY
OPERATE.
BUT BUT WHAT ABOUT A PUBLIC BANK
THAT SAYS THIS IS WHAT THE NEED
IS IN IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD IN OUR
COMMUNITIES MAYBE WE'RE NOT
YELLING THE BEST RETURN BUT IT'S
THE IT'S A PUBLIC GOAL IT AND WE
CAN HELP.
FINANCE -- US A FOUR WHEEL
HOUSING UNITS WE CAN HELP THE
FINANCE -- SENIOR HOUSE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT WAS SENIOR
HOUSING.
LOOK IN IN A PERFECT WORLD YOU
HEALTH FOR HOMEOWNERSHIP.
IT'S THAT ONE BRIDGE LOAN THAT
HELPS THE HELPS TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FOR FOR SOMEBODY TO
HAVE A TO BE ABLE -- TO PURCHASE
A HOME I'M I'M REALLY NOT THAT
SO I HAVE A LOT OF HOPES AND
ASPIRATIONS ULTIMATELY ALL NOT
BE ABLE TO TERMINATE BECAUSE THE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITY WILL BE ABLE
TO DETERMINE WHAT IS PUBLIC GOOD
IS.
BUT I THINK IT I I THINK IT
BEHOOVES US.
AS LITTLE AS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD TO TRY TO
SOLVE.
SOME OF THESE -- SOCIAL PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAD AND AND YOU'VE GOT
TO START BY SHAKING UP THE
SYSTEM AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. TO FIND A NEW
WAY TO DO IT.
IT'S NOT WORKING FOR FOLKS WE
GET IT WE HAVE.
A REAL QUICK SO WE HAVE --
CENTER TARA WOULD LIKE TO TO
SPEAK IF THAT WORKS ALREADY
GOING TO CENTER HERTZBERG AND
THEN BACK TO THE VICE CHAIR SEND
HER TIME.
THE CHAIR I SO I EIGHT SUPPORT
THE EFFORT TO SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT RIGHT -- I JUST.
I REPRESENT THE SENATE DISTRICT
THAT IS.
SUPER IMPOVERISHED WE STRUGGLE
WITH GETTING JUST ENOUGH MONEY.
OUR BASIC NEEDS LIKE.
WATER AND AND AND AND HEALTH
CARE -- AND MY CONCERN WITH THIS
THIS BILL IS.
THE LOS OBVIOUSLY -- BUT ALSO I
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF I
SUPPORT.
A BILL LIKE THIS BUT IT WORKS
FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT WORKS.
FOR A POPULATION THAT I
REPRESENT -- I MY DISTRICT MY
COMMUNITIES WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE ON THE PATH.
TOWARDS GETTING A PUBLIC BANK
BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
FUNDS.
AND SO I I AM NOT OPPOSED TO TO
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO YOU IN.
AND CONCEPT AYE AYE.
I DON'T DISAGREE.
BUT I WANT TO GET TO A PLACE AND
MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN TO
CONTINUE HAVE CONVERSATIONS I
CAN GET TO A POINT WHERE I CAN
SUPPORT IT.
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS AND THEIR NOT BEING
ADDRESSED BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT WORKS FOR MY
DISTRICT -- TO AND THAT IN THE
PROCESS THAT WE DON'T MAKE
THINGS WORSE. FOR MY COMMUNITY
AND AND ALL CALIFORNIANS IN THAT
BRIEF BUT IT WORKS FOR EVERYBODY
SO.
I WILL I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
IT TODAY BUT I WANT TO LEAVE THE
DOOR OPEN.
TO HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND IN MAKING SURE THAT -- YOU
CONTINUING A PATTERN THAT.
MAKE IT SUCCESSFUL IN THAT.
WE PROVIDE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
DID YOU JUST A VERY QUICK
RESPONSE SO FIRST OF ALL
PREVIOUS YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS.
THIS DEEPLY.
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO IN NORTH
DAKOTA THE SITUATION FACING THE
ROLE.
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES IN
NORTH DAKOTA WERE ACTUALLY QUITE
SIMILAR TO WHAT I THINK YOU ARE
GRAPPLING WITH IN YOUR DISTRICT
AND THE RESIDENTS OF NORTH
DAKOTA CHOSE AT THAT TIME TO
MOVE FOR WITH THE MODEL THAT IS
WORKING FOR THEM AND WORKING
WELL -- SECONDLY IF THERE ARE
OTHER IDEAS HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN
OTHER IDEAS THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE IT MORE
WORKABLE THIS BILL DOESN'T FORCE
ANY JURISDICTION TO DO ANYTHING
IT SIMPLY PROVIDES CHOICE.
AND IF THERE ARE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES OF WHICH THERE ARE
MANY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WANT TO
DO FOR MOVE THIS FORWARD.
MY HOPE IS WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH SEVERAL SUCCESSFUL
CHARTERS OF LOCAL PUBLIC BANKS
IT WILL BECOME A PROVEN MODEL.
AND AT THAT TIME CITIES AND AND
AND AND COUNTIES IN YOUR REGION --
WILL FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE AND
BE ABLE TO DO IT BUT APPRECIATE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE LOOK FOR TO THE
ONGOING CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I CENTER
TITLE SO WHAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO DO THAT WORKS FOR FOLKS WHO
LIKE TO GO TO CENTER HERTZBERG.
NO MISTER LANE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO OFFER A FEW COMMENTS AND
WE'D LIKE TO BE TO GO TO THE
VICE CHAIR.
SO I WOULD THINK YOU CAN CENTER
TARA WE'RE GONNA CENTER
HERTZBERG MYLINCOLN MISTER LANE
IN THE VICE CHAIR CENTER
HERTZBERG DIVERTED SPOKEN I JUST
BILL BRIEFLY TO ADD INTO THE
RICHNESS OF THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE FUTURE.
I TELL YOU THAT I THINK THAT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN ISSUE
WITH WHAT -- BELLS AND THE LIKE
WE'RE GONNA SEE TECHNOLOGY
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE WE HAVE
THREE MILLION UNBANKED UNDER
BANK PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE PEOPLE AT THE BOTTOM OF
THE LEVEL IN TERMS OF BANKING
THAT THEIR ASSOCIATION WITH
BANKING COSTS THEM.
HUGE PERCENTAGE OF THEIR MONEY
GO TO CHECK CASHING SERVICE AND
YOU WANT TO CHECK CASH A CHECK.
QUESTION BUNCH OF MONEY IN
TODAY'S TECHNOLOGY WITH
TELEPHONES WERE GOING TO COME UP
WITH WAYS WE CAN LITERALLY
DOWNLOAD.
YOUR YOUR CARD ON TO THE ONTO
YOUR PHONE YOU CAN PAY FOR
EVERYTHING WITH YOUR PHONE
TRANSACTION CHARGES WILL BE TO
MINIMUS.
ABILITY TO GET ACCESS TO CAPITAL
WE TO MINIMUS WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING ONLINE OF NEW WAYS
BANKING IS ALL ABOUT DETERMINING
TO DO A COUPLE OF THINGS OF YOUR
LOOK AT THE INVESTMENT SIDE.
AS TO WHETHER WE CAN SUPPORT THE
VALUES.
SECOND SIDE IS WHAT YOU DO THE
MONEY CAN YOU SUPPORT THE VALUES
AND HOW DOES THAT WORK.
WELL AND THE THIRD THING ABOUT
IT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR DOES IS IS
EVALUATE RISK.
IS SOMEBODY I'M GONNA GIVE A
LOAN TO WAR OVER ACCOUNT WITH A
THEY SOMEBODY'S RISKY WELL IF
YOU LOOK AT THE INTERNET TODAY.
THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF WAYS
EVEN IF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS THE LIKE.
YOU TALK TO THE THE BEST
THINKERS IN THE BANKING INDUSTRY.
YOU LITERALLY CAN DO BETTER RISK
PROFILES DETERMINING WHAT PEOPLE
DO ON THE INTERNET.
THEN YOU CAN BASED UPON -- THEIR
CREDIT PROFILE BECAUSE COULD
PROPOSES AND CONSIDERED FOR YOU
PAY YOUR YOUR YOUR UTILITY BILL
IT DOESN'T GET THE DECISION OF A
CREDIT CARD DOESN'T SAY YOU PAY
YOUR RENT TO PAY YOUR RENT IN
CASH.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF NEW
METHODOLOGIES SO WHEN WE LOOK TO
EXT TO TO SOLVE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE ARE FACING.
THE IMPACT ON PEOPLE WITH LESS
MEANS IN ALL OF THOSE A
REVOLUTION MY ONLY
RECOMMENDATION.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE SOME OF THE
STUFF IS TO TRADITIONAL BANKING.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS THINK
ABOUT IT PLATE WHAT WAYS THAT WE
HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT YOU KNOW
IN IN IN.
IN KENYA AND AFGHANISTAN THEY
ALL THE SOLDIERS GET PAID ON THE
TELEPHONE SO THIS IS THE
GENERAL'S CAN'T STEAL THE MONEY.
TRANSACTION COSTS ARE FRACTIONS
OF A PENNY COMPARE WOULD PEOPLE
PAY NOW THE AVAILABILITY OF
CREDIT ABILITY FOR SOMEONE ON A
CAL FRESH TO GET THEIR MONEY ON
THE PHONE.
AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND MOST
EVERYBODY HAS AND IF NOT.
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS THEY
SHOULD GIVE YOU THE PHONE
BECAUSE IT'S CHEAPER THAN THE
OTHER THINGS TO THE POINT YOU
RAISE WITH RESPECT TO PEOPLE
WITH LESS MONEY.
THE FUTURE IS BRIGHT THE
OPPORTUNITIES GREAT PEOPLE THE
MIDDLE AGAIN AGAINST THE MIDDLE
PEOPLE CAN GET SQUEEZED AND THIS
TO ME.
IS SOMETHING IS YOU BEGIN TO
ANALYZE THIS AND I SUSPECT
HOPEFULLY THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
INVOLVED TO REALLY ENGAGE
BECAUSE THERE ARE UNBELIEVABLE
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO TAKE CARE OF FOLKS GOING
FORWARD.
THIS WINTER LITERATURE
MISALIGNED THE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO RESPOND AS SENATOR
BILLS COMMENTS -- CALIFORNIA IS
IN FACT AN EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE
PLACE TO LIVE AND THAT IS NOT
LOST ON ME AS A RESIDENT AND
BUT THE INDUSTRY IS.
IF NOT THE MOST ONE OF THE MOST
HEAVILY REGULATED INDUSTRIES IN
THE UNITED STATES ITS BINS
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN COMPLIANCE COSTS ALONE.
IT HAS C. R. A. OBLIGATIONS
FULLY AT THE EFFORT IT PAYS
TAXES.
THE INDUSTRY PAYS IT'S EMPLOYEES
HIGHER WAGES THAN THE MINIMUM
WAGE.
IT IS FANCIFUL TO THINK THAT A
PUBLIC BANK WON'T SIMILARLY HOW
AFTER INCURRING THOSE COMPLIANCE
COSTS AND IT WON'T HAVE TO
CHARGE FEES.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT THE CASE.
RELATIVE TO THE COMMENT MADE
THAT THE PUBLIC THINKS THAT THE
INDUSTRY HAS FAILED IT.
THE DATA DOESN'T BEAR THAT OUT
THE POLLING THAT WE'VE CONDUCTED
BY SOME FAIRLY WELL KNOWN
POLLSTERS SAY THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE BEING SERVED.
BY THEIR CREDIT UNIONS AND THEIR
BANKS AND I WOULD JUST SAY THIS
IF THAT'S THE TRUTH IF THE IF
THE PUBLIC SENTIMENT IS SUCH.
THAT THE PUBLIC THINKS THE
BANKING INDUSTRY HAS FAILED THEM.
THEN WHY NOT PUT THE PUBLIC
THANK QUESTION TO A VOTE OF
EVERY CITY IN CALIFORNIA INSTEAD
OF JUST GENERAL LOST CITIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND.
YEAH I THINK WE HAVE A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE MY PERSPECTIVE IS TO
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HARMED.
AND YOU KNOW THE QUESTION IS ARE
THEY BEING HARMED YES THEY ARE.
AND AND YOU KNOW YEAH YOU'RE
REGULATED BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
REGULATIONS THAT YOU INFLUENCE
THE WRITING OF SO.
ON FOR ME FOR ME QUITE FRANKLY
I'M I'M.
FOR FOCUSING A LITTLE BIT.
ON THOSE PEOPLE THAT DON'T GET
ENOUGH FOCUS WHICH IS THE 20%.
OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S AND POVERTY.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THAT
ARE RESPONSIBLE.
PEOPLE THAT ARE UNDER OUR CHARGE
AS A PUBLIC AGENCY.
WHETHER IT'S THE COUNTY OR THE
STATE OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT ARE UNABLE TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY BEING CHARGED.
BEING CHARGED RIGHT NOW.
AND I I I THINK THAT'S ON TALL
AND UNACCEPTABLE [inaudible]
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
GIVEN HE FACT THAT WE'VE HAD
SUCH A HARD TIME.
PROVIDE THEM WITH HOUSING FOOD
SHELTER -- PROGRAMS FOR THEM.
IT'S IT'S UNACCEPTABLE TO CHARGE
HIM SO THAT'S ACTIVE THEN THE
BANK SIDE I I REALIZE THAT AN I
I'M I'M ELECTED TO REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE IN MY MY COMMUNITY.
AND MY PERSPECTIVE IS VERY WELL
KNOWN AND LIKE.
OKAY SO I I THAT'S THE WAY I
FEEL.
AND I'D BE WILLING TO CONSIDER A
PUBLIC [inaudible]
BANK OPTION.
I THINK THERE IS.
SOMETHING IS WILLING.
TO WE SHOULD BE WILLING TO
EXPLORE THE SUBJECT SO THAT'S
WHY I WOULD SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR CENTER WITH A
TURN OVER THE VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER LANE I
YOU WERE YOU DIDN'T BONTA THE
SPECIFIC CONCERN ABOUT SSI.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
DIRECT DEPOSIT AN AUTOMATIC
CHARGES OUT OF A CHECKING
ACCOUNT.
THERE ARE NO CHARGES.
AN EIGHT DOLLAR FEE?
I'M NOT SURE THERE MAY BE A FEE
TO MAINTAIN THE CHECKING ACCOUNT
THAT DOESN'T HAVE DIRECT DEPOSIT.
SO THE I MEAN THERE IS A
CONSTANT ISSUING SO -- USING THE
SERVICE AND AND MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT HE'S REFERRING TO I I DON'T
KNOW.
A A WITHOUT SPECIFIC.
INFORMATION I COULDN'T ANSWER
THE QUESTION -- AHEAD OF
RELIGIOUS YOU'RE SITTING ON THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
AND EVERY TIME THE STATE AUDITOR
COMES OUT WITH A REPORT I JUST
CRINGE.
THE STATE CAN'T RUN ANYTHING
CAN'T RUN THE DMV.
CAN'T RUN HIGH SPEED RAIL.
CAN'T RUN CALTRANS SPENDING
THREE TIMES THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
ON REPAIRING ROADS.
SO I MISSED YOUR I'VE.
I I'M I'M SCARED TO DEATH.
HONESTLY TO SEE OF THE STATE
TRYING TO RUN A BANK IT JUST IT
WOULD MYSTIFIED ME YOU GOT TO
READ THESE REPORTS I WISH I HAD
A REPORT ONCE FROM.
OUR STATE DAUGHTER THAT SAID
THIS DEPARTMENTS RUNNING GREAT
AND THERE'S NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT EVERYTHING'S FINE IT'S NOT
NO INTRO CONTROLLED.
YOUR BUT I'M I'M ARE THESE
REPORTS HAVE BEEN.
EXTREMELY DISTURBING.
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR I I
I'M OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH IT'S I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT STATE
WOULD NOT BE RUNNING THE BANK
COULD BE A LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IT JUST BAFFLES ME THAT --
WHILE THE STATE HAS CHALLENGES I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO GO TAKE A LOOK
AT MISSISSIPPI.
COURAGE YOU GO TAKE A LOOK AT
KENTUCKY.
URGE YOU TO GO LOOK AT THE
MEXICO GO LOOK AT SEVERAL OTHER
STATES SEE HOW THEY RUN THE
CHALLENGES THEY HAVE.
BEEN COMPARED WITH CALIFORNIA.
SO JUST WOULD ENCOURAGE SOME
ADDITIONAL DUE DILIGENCE ON THAT --
CENTER BELL THERE ANY OTHER
ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ANY ADDITIONAL -- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE FROM THE DICE PLACE
IN A WINNER.
VERY BRIEFLY I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I
THINK WE SHOULD GIVE OUR CITIES.
THE OPTIONS -- TO DO THAT CITING
THERE'S A THERE'S ALWAYS A THIS
PUSH BACK AND HOSTILITY.
AGAINST.
GOVERNMENT DOING THINGS AND THIS
WHOLE NOTION THAT GOVERNMENT
CAN'T DO ANYTHING RIGHT NOW AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE CHALLENGES
AND SOME OF OUR AGENCIES.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT?
MANY OF THE THINGS THE
GOVERNMENT.
IS THE HAS DONE REALLY WELL LIKE
SOCIAL SECURITY OR THE
GOVERNMENT WORK THAT LED TO THE
INTERNET BEING CREATED I MEAN
THERE'S A GOVERNMENT IS ABLE TO
DO THINGS WELL NOT ALWAYS BUT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR FRANKLY ALSO.
MESSES THINGS UP BUT WHEN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR ALMOST DESTROYED
OUR ECONOMY AND TWO THOUSAND AND
EAT OR THEREABOUTS THAT WAS THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT WAS NOT
GOVERNMENT.
SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK WE SHOULD ALLOW
CITIES TO TRY THIS OUT NICE.
MUCH PLEASE ENTER YOUR MAIN
SILENCE THAT WERE COMING TO THE
END AND I MUST SPEAK OUT I HAVE
SOME EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
ACTUALLY AT THE BALLOT.
MANY YEARS AGO WHEN I FIRST RAN
FOR THE SENATE MY OPPONENT HAD
AUTHORED A BILL TO CREATE A
STATE BANK.
THAT BECAME A HUGE ISSUE
[inaudible]
AN ELECTION.
AND I WAS ABLE TO PREVAIL IN A
SIXTY THIRTY DISTRICT.
IN NO SMALL PART BECAUSE OF THE
DISTRUSTED PEOPLE HAD BEEN
TRUSTING.
THANKS THE STATE RUN THE BANKS.
OVER THE DECADES MY EXPERIENCE
IN DEALING WITH GOVERNMENT.
AND I'M FOLLOWING ON UNDER
MORLOCKS OBSERVATIONS.
SHOWS ME THE GOVERNMENT GETS
VERY LITTLE RIGHT.
WE HAVE SQUANDERED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
ON A TRAIN.
MULTI BILLION DOLLARS ON ALL THE
HIGH TECH PROJECTS WE TRIED TO
DEPLOY IN CALIFORNIA.
NONE OF THEM COME IN ON TIME AND
ALL INCOME IN WAY OVER BUDGET.
AND IT IT JUST SHOWS ME THAT
THIS WOULD BE A VERY RISKY THING.
TO TRUST.
THE GOVERNMENT.
THE RUN OUR BANKS.
THERE MAY BE FAILURES OF COURSE
WITH REGULAR BANKS BUT THE
RECORD OF GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
GIVE ONE COMFORT.
IN TERMS OF AN AUTHORITY TO
MANAGE.
I AM SORRY I CANNOT SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SERIOUS AND
THINK OF THE BY CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE.
BEFORE WE TURN IT OVER TO ASSN
MEMBER CHIU INSIDE JENNIFER
CLOSING COMMENTS ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL.
LAST MINUTE COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. NINETY NINE WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
CURRENTLY IN THE MOTIONS BY
CENTER WIENER THIS IS A DO
PASSES A MINIATURE PREPARATIONS.
MOTION.
MR SIMILAR FOR SURE SURPLUS
INCOME LET ME AGAIN VERY MUCH
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
YOUR YOUR IN DEPTH DISCUSSION A
REFLECTION AND AGAIN I WANT VERY
MUCH THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT ON THIS
ISSUE [inaudible]
AND AND I DON'T WE COULD
PROBABLY HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ROLE OF
THE PUBLIC SECTOR AND IN THE
ROLE OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC ROADS IN PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND PUBLICLY RUN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND FIRE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO JUST FOCUS ON
THIS AS IT STANDS.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL IT'S ABOUT PROVIDING
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHO BELIEVE
THAT THEIR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
COULD BE BETTER PUT TO USE.
IF THEY COULD CONTROL IT THROUGH
A LOCAL CHARTER PUBLIC BANK --
AND THIS IS ABOUT LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT.
THAT DO NOT THINK THAT THE
LARGEST WALL STREET BANKS ARE
ARE ARE SERVING THEM.
THE OPPOSITION POINTED TO
POLLING.
SUGGESTING THAT SOMEHOW THAT'S
DIFFERENT BUT I IF YOU LISTEN
CAREFULLY HE REFERRED.
TO CREDIT UNIONS AND AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE FAILURE
OF THE LARGEST WALL STREET BANKS
TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY KERN
SIMPLE.
THIS BILL.
WITH LANGUAGE SPECIFICALLY SAYS
WE DON'T WANT TO COMPETE IN THE
LANES OF CREDIT UNIONS ARE
COMMUNITY BANKS THAT ARE TRYING
TO SERVE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT WHEN YOU'VE GOT HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS BEING
INVESTED IN PLACES WHERE ARE
COMMUNITIES DO NOT WANT TO BE
INVESTED.
AND NOT INVEST IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY THAT IS NOT SERVING US.
IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
JUST CLARIFY AND THIS IS BEEN
SAID BEFORE BY NUMBER OF PARTIES
BUT I THINK IT BEARS TO BE SAID
BECAUSE I DO KNOW THERE'S SOME
CONFUSION THE PUBLIC.
THE LANGUAGE WE ARE TAKING AN
AMENDMENT.
WOULD REQUIRE -- THAT WE GO TO
THE BALLOT BOX WITH REGARDS TO
GENERAL LOST CITIES.
AND US CITIES IT TAKE PART IN
GPI GPAS BUT IT WOULD APPLY TO
CHARTER CITIES BECAUSE THOSE
CITIES ARE ALREADY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY.
ON THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS AND WE DO NOT
WANT TO UNDERMINE THAT -- AND
THAT IS THE UNDERSTANDING WE
HAVE WITH THE CHAIR HAS BEEN
STATED SEVERAL TIMES WITH THE
OPPOSITION BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE
THAT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
LET ME JUST SEND WITH THE
FOLLOWING WHICH IS.
WITH THIS BILL.
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO KEEP TAXPAYER DOLLARS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES RATHER
THAN CONTINUING TO SEND RECORD
PROFITS. TO WALL STREET BANKS.
TO CREATE LOCAL JOBS TO BUILD
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE TO
STABILIZE LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PUBLIC'S.
MONEY SHOULD SERVE A PUBLIC
PURPOSE AND NOT MAXIMIZE PROFITS
SHAREHOLDERS AND FUNDAMENTALLY
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT THE SALMON MR
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I'LL BE BRIEF I A
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK FOR THE
COMMITTEES IDOL AND I APPRECIATE.
THE ROBUST CONVERSATION I AT ONE
OF THE COMMITTEES RIGHT
APPRECIATED THE ACTUAL BACK AND
FORTH ON RULE POLICY ISSUES AND
YOU KNOW I TAKE AWAY FROM THIS
EVEN THOSE WHO WHO ARE NOT GONNA
BE SUPPORTED THE DAY TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A WEALTH OF
INFORMATION.
THAT YOU'VE LEARNED.
THAT CAN HELP THIS TO BECOME A
BETTER BILL MOVING FOR NIGHT AND
I'D APPRECIATE THAT SORT OF
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I THINK.
I READ THE COMMENTS TO BE YOU'RE
NOT TOO FAR OFF.
IN TERMS OF IN TERMS OF
APPRECIATING THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE AND I
APPRECIATE ARE YOU GOING TO THAT
LENGTH EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE NOT
SUPPORT TODAY -- SO THAT WOULD
WITH THAT I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS -- DEEP INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS ISSUE I REALLY DO --
OFTENTIMES YOU GET -- HEAVY DUTY
BILLS AGO THROUGH COMMITTEE AND
YOU DON'T SPEND A LOT OF TIME ON
THE CHAIRS REALLY TAKEN THE TIME.
TO DIG INTO THE WEEDS TO HOW
LONG CONVERSATIONS TO HAVE LONG
MEETINGS AND AND IT'S NOT LAS
APPRECIATED.
VERY MUCH BY US SO THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY TO MAKE
YOU SOME NUMBERS VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT AS WELL --
IN ALWAYS OF WORKING WITH BOTH
YOU WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
OPPOSITION FOR PROVIDING OTHER
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR SUCH A ROBUST
DISCUSSION.
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR IS TO PASS
IS A MINUTE APPROPRIATIONS
MISSING JUST ROLL CALL PLEASE.
HI WHY I'M MORE LOT.
NOBEL WELL I HERTZBERG.
I DON'T KNOW NIELSEN.
YES NO WAY INNER.
IT'S A FOUR THREE VOTE THE BILL
IS OUT AND WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE ON ITEM NUMBER SIX THANK
CENTERS A. FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
MASON GENERAL COMMITTEE WE'RE
GONNA GET OURSELVES ORGANIZED
WE'RE GONNA ADD EVERYONE ON AND
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE IT DOWN -- FOR
THE WEEK WE ARE GONNA BE HAVING
HEARING IN JULY TENTH
ASSUME EVER MORE LOCK IS ALREADY
PREPARING BRING IN A TENT AND A
SLEEPING BAG IS THIS NEXT
HEARING.
NEXT WEEK WILL PROBABLY BE ABOUT
A SIX HOUR HEARING IS WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE -- IN SO THEN WE WILL
ALSO HAVE A HEARING ON AUGUST
FOURTEENTH IS WELL AUGUST
FOURTEENTH.
WILL BE -- CENTER HERTZBERG
FAVORITE HEARING OF THE YEAR THE
TAX LEVY HEARING.
THE IT'S IT'S VERY EXCITING --
DANG WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH
YOU JULY TENTH AUGUST FOURTEENTH
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH YOU AS
WE GET OURSELVES ORGANIZED.
ONCE AND I WENT OVER OUR WORD
AGAIN.
YES I DID JIM ARE COMING BACK
CENTER TADO IS FIRED UP PRETTY
GO WE NEED TO GIVE A ROUND OF
APPLIES CENTER TITLE WHO IS OUR
OR RICARDO LARA WE'RE GOING TO
TODAY. FOR THE NINTH WEEK IN A
ROW LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS IS
AMAZING.
THIS IS THE MAIN SUCCESS SAID
THIS IS FANTASTIC -- THAT'S
RIGHT I WAS I DO APOLOGIZE
SENATOR BELL YOU'RE AT YOU'RE
RIGHT I WILL -- AT HOUSING
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY IS A LEADER
DID WIN THE MIKE MCGUIRE AWARD
FOR ARRIVING LATE YOU KNOW WHAT
SEVERAL WEEKS IN A ROW REALLY
YOU KNOW WHAT'S INNER WIENER AYE
YAY -- THANK YOU SO MUCH HI.
HEY HI DAVE -- WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRISON -- I'M GONNA ASK
CENTER TODD -- INTO WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT TO THE
MAJORITY LEADER HERE TODAY FOR
THE RICARDO LARA AWARD.
I HAVE AN EMPTY CUP OF COFFEE.
THANK YOU GENTLEMEN APPLIES
MAYES EIGHTY SO MUCH REGULATIONS
THAT HERTZBERG GIVE ANY --
PARTING WORDS.
IT IS A GREAT HONOR AND
DISTINCTION AND PRIDE.
AND YOU MIL OF THE THAT I ACCEPT
THIS RICARDO LARA AWARD THAT'S
WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH
THAT'S AMAZING HAPPY FOURTH OF
JULY EVERYBODY LET'S GET RIGHT
INTO AND GET FOLKS ADDED ON THAT
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
ALSO ON WHO CUTS YOU WHEN YOU'RE
LATE TO SEE THERE WE GO I LIKE
IT I LIKE IT.
THE CONTENT COUNTER ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB SIXTY FIVE AND ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE I KNOW CONSENT COUNTER
KISSING UNDER I CAN THINK AN
ITEM TO AB SIXTY FIVE IN ITEM.
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN OH NINE I
CURRENT LOTUS FIVE ZERO MUSLIM
CHESTER.
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER.
BECAUSE IN COUNTER IS OUT WE ARE
CLOSE IN THE ROLE. SEVEN ZERO
ONE FIVE TWO FIVE NOW TO BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FORTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
IS FOR ONE THIS LAND JUST
[inaudible]
I DON'T [inaudible]
I WIENER.
WIENER I SIX ONE THE BILL IS OUT
WILL CLOSE IN THE ROLE. FOR NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM THREE ITEM
THREE AB.
SIX NINETY FOUR YES ID YEP THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MANAGER
PREPARATIONS CURRENT VOTERS FOR
ONE TO ST CHESTER [inaudible]
I WIENER. SIX ONE THAT BILL IS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ITEM NUMBER
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN THE
MOTION. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FIVE EIGHT ZERO MESSAGES --
GUY WIENER.
BIPARTISAN IS FROM SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS APPLE CLOSING THE
ROOM.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB EIGHT SEVEN
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
MISCELLANEOUS [inaudible]
I WIENER.
THAT'S A SEVEN ZERO VOTE THAT
BILL IS APPLE LITTLE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MANAGER PREPARATION.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO MISSING
JUST [inaudible]
I WIENER.
AT VOTE IS FIVE SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
ITEM NUMBER NINE EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASTOR PERFORATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ONE MISSING
CHESTER WIRE HIGH FLYER.
I WIENER.
WIENER.
VOTE IS SIX TWO ONE THE BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE IN A
ONE TAKE MOM TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SEND WINNER. FOR HIS ASSISTANCE
ON THAT BILL IS WELL IN THE
PARTNERSHIP IS A MEMBER LACKEY.
WOULD LIKE TO BE A LOOK AT ITEM
NUMBER TEN A. B. SIXTEEN OH
SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER ****
BATH EMOTION IS DO PASS.
AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS
CURRENT VOTERS FOR SERVICE AND
JUST [inaudible]
I WIENER.
THAT IS A SEVEN ZERO VOTE THE
BILL'S APPLE.
FINAL I'M OF THE DAY ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR KERN VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO MISS LANCASTER [inaudible]
I WIENER.
THANKS FOR THE PEOPLE OF THAT
BILL IS OUT FOR CLOSING THE ROLE
HOPE EVERYONE HAS A WONDERFUL
FOURTH OF JULY WE'LL SEE YEAH.
BACK HERE NINE THIRTY EIGHT AM
NEXT WEDNESDAY.
THE WORK OF THE GOV AND FIGHT
TEAM.
WHAT MORE WORK TO COME UP FOR
THE NEXT WEEK LIVING THE DREAM
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND